bonsoir tout le monde merci d'avoir
bravé les foudres du coronavirus pour
vous réunira plus de je ne sais pas
combien dans cette salle le cahier des
charges qu'on m'a donné ce soir est
d'essayer de mélanger enfin vous de
bélanger de regrouper trois angles
dans un seul et même sujet qui sont la
question énergétique la question du
changement climatique et la question
alors j'étais très scolaire je suis
désolé on m'a dit méditerranée donc je
vais parler de quelques pays limitrophes
de la méditerranée avant d'avoir compris
que la méditerranée pouvait aller
jusqu'en russie m'a dit pascal
heylbroeck limitée à quelques pays qui
sont plus d'un dans mon acception on va
dire plus plus plus étroite de la
méditerranée je vais donc vous parler à
la fois donc d'énergie d'eau qui va me
dire je suis ravi d'avoir l'occasion de
faire ça ici parce que ce que je vais
essayer de vous dire notamment c'est
qu'il ya à l'évidence un enjeu
sécuritaire extrêmement important dans
cette affaire de changement climatique
et d'énergie et qui aujourd'hui est de
mon point de vue pas pris à son bon
niveau
alors comme tout comme tout individu qui
se respecte je vais démarrer ma
dissertation vous savez quand vous avez
une dissertation donc on vous dit
énergie changement climatique
méditerranée donc vous faites
commencez par définir les termes que
vous avez manipulé
donc je vais commencer par vous parler
d'énergie
il ya dans les débats publics concernant
l'énergie plein de manières de prendre
ce terme d'accor
une première manière de prendre ce terme
est de dire l'énergie est un truc qui
s'achètent puisque de fait les gens
passent à la pompe pour acheter de
l'essence de fait les gens reçoivent des
factures qui ont payé l'électricité du
gaz etc et donc l'énergie je peux le
voir comme une facture de fait quand
vous parlez d'énergie à une entreprise
en général elles voient ça comme une
facture quand vous parlez d'énergie à
des consommateurs ils ont généralement
assez facilement en ville voir ça comme
une facture quand on s'intéresse à
l'énergie et les ménages souvent c'est
pour parler de factures quand on demande
au gilet jaune or ça c'est sûr qu'ils
vous parlent de factures je suis pas sûr
que le militaire verra ça avant tout
comme une facture
pas complètement sûr il ya quand même un
service des essences alors mais si ma
mémoire est bonne et il ya quand même
une idée que l'énergie ça va avec la
chaîne logistique
mais dans la population dans son
ensemble la facture est quelque chose
qui est très courant et alors
malheureusement quand on commence à
penser facture on est parti sur un
mauvais chemin
parce qu entendent à ce que vos
l'énergie dans ce qu'on dépense c'est
souvent des très petites factures et du
reste je vais faire un test tout de
suite
alors je vais prendre tous les étudiants
qui ont eu peur de se mettre au premier
rang qui était depuis dans cette salle
voilà ce que dans les eaux n a pas
beaucoup dans les étudiants est ce que
il y en a qui sont locataires dans ceux
qui sont locataires qui ne connaît pas
le montant de son loyer dans ceux qui
sont locataires qui ne connaît pas le
montant exact de sa dernière facture
d'électricité connaissez le montant
exact de vos dernières factures
d'électricité non dont vous auriez dû
lever la donc le voilà ce petit test est
là pour montrer que quand vous avez
affaire à une grosse facture les gens
savent que c'est une grosse fait
faillite ils connaissent le montant
parce que vous connaissez le montant des
contractures et dans une entreprise
c'est exactement pareil les gens ils ont
en tête les gros montants
quand c'est un petit montant en fait on
n'y fait pas attention et il se trouve
que l'énergie est un petit montant le je
ne sais pas combien ça vaut au sein de
la marine nationale les achats d'énergie
mais par contre je sais combien ça vaut
au sein de la sncf qui m'a amené ici la
sncf qui est le premier consommateur
électrique de france est probablement un
des premiers consommateurs de carburant
parce que ils ont plein de trains qui
roulent au diesel
plus qu'un jeu peut avoir mais plus la
première flotte de bus qui est qui
keolis plus une flotte de camions énorme
s'appelle geodis chez eux ces quelques %
de leur chiffre d'affaires
c'est pas bon et chez les ménages quand
vous regardez les dépenses domestiques
d'énergie c'est-à-dire gaz électricité
fioul pour le chauffage séquelles
électricité ces quelques pourcents de ce
que les gens gagnent et les carburants
c'est aussi quelques pourcents de ce que
les gens gagnent donc quand on a une
petite dépense dans le monde économique
qui nous entoure en général on y fait
attention une petite partie du temps et
le reste du temps on s'occupe d'autre
chose de sujets beaucoup plus sérieux
comme par exemple les retraites ce que
vous allez voir à la fin de cet exposé
c'est qu'en fait la discussion qu'on a
en ce moment sur leur retraite est une
discussion sur le sexe des anges parce
que justement le fait de ne pas
comprendre ce que veut vraiment dire
l'énergie fait qu' on est en train de
faire des plans pour l'avenir dont on
est absolument certain qu'il ne se
réaliseront pas à cause du fait qu' on
n'a pas bien compris ce qu'était
l'énergie donc ce raisonnement est à peu
près aussi sensée que si je disais bon
ben la masse de votre cervelle ces 2 %
de votre poids donc si je peux m'en
occuper 2 % du temps je peux l'oxygéner
2 % du temps je peut l'alimenter de
constant du temps ou bien je peux vous
enlevez la moitié c'est pas très grave
vous perdrez 1 % d'efficacité dans votre
corps évidemment ce n'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut raisonner le lien de
dépendance entre votre cervelle et le
reste du corps font que si je vous
enlève votre cervelle cerveau représenté
2 % de votre poids le reste ne
fonctionne plus et bien l'énergie c'est
exactement pareil si vous enlève
l'énergie sarrebourg représenter
quelques pourcents de ce qu'on paye le
reste ne fonctionne plus tout le reste
s'arrête la deuxième manière qu'on a de
penser par le deuxième réflexe pavlovien
qu'on a souvent en ce qui concerne
l'énergie
sl des économies alors j'ai fait un
petit test ya pas très longtemps j'ai
demandé à google
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient comment il
avait envie de me compléter maroc est si
je démarre une requête en mettant la
meilleure énergie c'est google à ce
moment il vaut complète avec la requête
la plus couramment fait est alors à ce
moment google complète la requête avec
c'est celle qu'on ne consomme pas alors
manque de pot c'est exactement l'inversé
qui s'est passé de l'énergie on en
utilise de plus en plus depuis longtemps
donc probablement que la meilleure
énergie c'est celle qu'on consomme
parce que si c'était celle qu'on
consomme pas on en aurait consommé de
moins en moins parce que c'est quand
même vachement sympa de se mettre dans
une situation où on a ce qu'il ya de
mieux vous avez ici la quantité totale
d'énergie utilisée par les hommes depuis
un siècle et demi et vous voyez que
manifestement on n'a pas trop écouter ce
slogan on a fait l'exact inverse
et alors vous noterez deux choses
intéressantes sur cette courbe c'est que
la tertiarisation de l'économie
n'interrompt absolument pas la housse
donc en fait la tertiarisation de
l'économie qui dématérialise réelles
économies c'est un slogan c'est pas une
réalité
et la deuxième chose que vous voyez sur
cette courbe c'est que la
dématérialisation de l'économie qui
viendraient de la diffusion des
technologies numériques c'est aussi un
slogan c'est pas une réalité encore donc
ni le numérique ni la tertiarisation de
l'économie n'ont fait quoi que ce soit
pour infléchir la hausse de la quantité
d'énergie qu'on utilise sur terre et en
fait je vous épargne les statistiques ce
soir mais si vous regardez le nombre de
gens qui travaillent dans le tertiaire
en fonction de la quantité d'énergie
utilisée par personne dans le monde
vous vous rendez compte que plus on
utilise d'énergie par personne et plus
la part des emplois dans le tertiaire
augmente et on verra pourquoi un peu
plus tard c'est parfaitement normal que
ce soit comme ça il ya un troisième
réflexe pavlovien qui vient maintenant
souvent à l'esprit en ce qui concerne
l'énergie c'est de dire que on va aller
vers un monde totalement renouvelable et
que c'est ça l'avenir alors de fait un
monde totalement renouvelable
on sait faire on a fait très longtemps
voilà par exemple un monde totalement
renouvelable
vous allez prendre le monde ya cinq
siècles il est totalement renouvelable
à cette époque là il n'y a pas un gramme
de pétrole de charbon ni de nucléaire tu
restes qui est utilisé par les hommes
nous sommes dans un univers 100 %
renouvelable alors la question c'est si
l'univers 100% renouvelable est si
merveilleux pourquoi est-ce que ça fait
des siècles qu'on s'évertue à faire
l'exact inverse de ce qu il faudrait
qu'on fasse aujourd'hui parce que de
fait ça fait des siècles qu'on fait
l'exact inverse
voyez voilà la marine à voile dit lira
quelques siècles
donc ça allait un peu moins vite qu'une
frégate moderne c'était un peu moins
puissant qu'un porte avions modernes et
on s'est dit bon on va remplacer sa part
une marine fossiles ça sera quand même
plus efficace pour alimenter le
supermarché du coin
rapidement on avait des transports
terrestres parfaitement nous la voyez un
cheval renouvelables du reste à la fin
on renouvelait en mangeant une charrette
en bois bah oui à l'époque où il y avait
des animaux de trait ont valorisé les
animaux de trait en fin de vie c'est
pour ça qu'on avait les boucheries
chevalines totalement disparu maintenant
qu'il est chez votre trait voulent qui
manger de l'herbe renouvelables en
tirant une charrette à boire etc
puis on s'est dit que fossilisés les
transports ça les arrange est quand même
un peu plus efficaces donc c'est ce
qu'on a fait on avait une agriculture
renouvelables voyage animaux de trait
renouvelables etc
puis on s'est dit quand même que pour
nourrir les étudiants pour pêcheurs
s'étaient mieux d'avoir une agriculture
fossiles on avait une industrie
parfaitement renouvelables avec des
moulins à vent des moulins à eau etc et
on s'est dit que quand même pour
fabriquer tout ce qui nous entoure
aujourd'hui c'était plus simple donc en
gros ça fait quelques siècles
compass l'exacte qu'on passe notre temps
à faire l'exact inverse du slogan à la
mode d'aujourd'hui qui est on va aller
vers un monde 100 % renouvelable
alors de deux choses l'une ou bien nos
ancêtres ont été des crétins patenté à
faire l'exact inverse de ce qu il
faudrait faire aujourd'hui
ou bien il ya quand même une toute
petite raisons physiques à ce que c'est
comme ça que ce soit écrit l'histoire et
pas autrement parce que voyez les
moulins à vent dont les éoliennes
modernes sont une variante on connaît ça
depuis 2000 ans ça fait 2000 ans
concorder les moulins à vent donc si les
moulins à vent c'est intrinsèquement
supérieur c'est pas cher et c'est
pourquoi est ce qu'on sait en kittin et
à abandonner les moulins à vent pour
utiliser autre chose
si vraiment c'est pas cher c'est comme
un mode on peut en faire ce qu'on veut
alors en fait on joue vous donne un tout
petit exemple qui va vous montrer que la
raison pour laquelle on a fait ça c'est
pas juste parce qu'on était des êtres
malfaisants c'est que malheureusement la
physique nous a poussés et que violer la
physique c'est compliqué si on imagine
comprend le volume d'air de cette salle
qui en première approximation doit pas
être très très loin du volume d'air d'un
culte d'heure de 10 mètres de côté
donc je prends mille mètres cubes d'air
jeu j'ai pris ma cette master
une vitesse d'un mistral correct 80 km
heure 45 2 puisque a démarré dans la
salle et je fais passer ça dans une
éolienne
je vais donc dans un moulin à vent
modernes je vais évidemment récupérer de
l'énergie et bien la quantité d'énergie
que je vais récupérer est équivalente à
celle que j'ai en faisant brûler 3000
litres de pétrole beaucoup trop vivre
question est-ce que c'est plus simple
tant qu'on n'a pas de problème de
disponibilité sur le pétrole d'utiliser
3000 litres de pétrole pour lesquels il
ya qu'à faire un trou dans la terre et à
le faire sortir et avec ce pétrole le
bateau avance quand il ya du vent quand
ya pas de vent quand il fait nuit quand
il fait jour j'ai exactement quand on a
décidé de le faire sortir quoi alors que
avec l'électricité éolienne les docks
avec l'énergie éolienne plus
généralement et bien le train de 8
heures par s'il ya du vent et il n'y a
pas de vent il part pas bien évidemment
c'est physiquement beaucoup plus simple
d'utiliser l'énergie avec la modalité de
droite qu'avec la modalité de gauche et
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle on
est historiquement passer des énergies
renouvelables aux énergies fossiles et
pâle inverse
il ya une raison physique et sa très
accessoirement noter que l'éolienne
moderne est un sous-ensemble de notre
économie fossiles puisque pour faire
l'éolienne moderne il faut du charbon
pour faire la métallurgie
il faut du pétrole pour faire la
pétrochimie amont et les transports de
tout les morceaux intermédiaire ya pas
plus mondialisé que l'éolien et le
solaire
les dix premiers fabricants de panneaux
solaires sont en chine est aujourd'hui
le premier fabricant de nacelles sont en
chine également
donc quand on installe une éolienne ou
un panneau solaire en dix ans et de
l'énergie locales dont ces d'énergie
chinoise vers l'énergie et l'eau calme
et le collecteur lui il est totalement
mondialisé
c'est pas plus local qu'autre chose et
il vous faut du gaz pour faire tourner
les cimenteries pour installer les plots
en béton
voilà donc le prix aujourd'hui barre de
l'éolien c'est tout simplement parce
qu'on à l'énergie fossile à l'amont pour
faire des éoliennes pour pas cher
le jour où vous bouclez de systèmes sur
lui même et où vous n'avez plus que des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires pour
faire d'autres éoliennes et d'autres
panneaux solaires on reparlera du prix
de l'éolien pas complètement sûr que ça
reste la houssaye
donc une facture c'est réducteur
l'économiser c'est parce qu'on a fait
100 % renouvelable
on en sort est en fait là le vrai
rapport qu'on doit avoir vis-à-vis de
l'énergie ce qu'on doit comprendre ce
qui concerne l'énergie c'est que
l'énergie c'est ce qui nous a permis de
nous tailler un costume de superman pour
de vrai et c'est pour ça qu'on aime
énormément l'énergie parce qu'en fait
qu'est-ce que l'énergie l'énergie c'est
des croquettes pour machines teisseire
l'énergie c'est ce qui permet de faire
fonctionner des machines et donc grâce à
l'énergie
on a pu augmenter notre corps donc
l'augmenter et l'afld avaient augmenté
c'est une réalité c'est pas un truc qui
est futuriste et cetera c'est une
réalité augmentée l'être humain c'est ce
qu'on vient de faire sur les deux
siècles qui se sont écoulés et nous
avons adjoint à nos bras et à nos jambes
des engins surpuissant un laminoir à
porte avions un porte-conteneurs un
train avion etc et l'ensemble de ces
engins surpuissant ont fait de nous ça
alors c'est pas un truc qu'on porte sur
nous vous ne portez pas le laminoir sur
votre dos mais par contre nous avons
créé pour chacun d'eux pour chaque
terrien un costume de superman dont la
jambe gauche c'est d'évaporateurs et des
cimenteries et des aciéries et la jambe
droite
des porte conteneurs et un système
ferroviaire et des voitures et le bras
gauche c'est l'ensemble du système
numérique mondiale qui consomme
énormément d'énergie et le bras droit
c'est tous les tracteurs et tous les
aspirateurs et où les tous les chariots
élévateurs et tous les ascenseurs de la
terre et c'est donc en fait nous l'avons
vraiment créer un costume de superman et
ce costume de superman
il fonctionne à l'énergie voilà c'est ça
l'énergie si je prends est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un dans la salle qui a déjà fait
quatre mille mètres de dénivelé dans la
journée 1
donc je vais donner le micro il
racontera aux autres alors j'ai une très
bonne nouvelle pour lui il est ridicule
or les autres le sont encore plus
l'huile est ridicule alors je vais vous
dire pourquoi il est ridicule quand vous
faites 4000 mètres de dénivelé dans la
journée et que vous hissez votre propre
corps contre le champ gravitationnel
vous allez fournir de l'énergie
mécanique que vous allez en général
fournir avec vos jambes et bien un petit
calcul simple vous montre que si vous
faites cet effort dans la journée vous
aurez fournit un kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique avec vos jambes ce
qui est pas beaucoup et si vous mettez
10 heures vous l'avez pas fait en 2h01
rassurez moi non si vous mettez 10
heures pour faire cet exercice est bien
vos jambes ont fourni pendant les 10
heures où elles ont travaillé une
énergie mécanique qui est de l'ordre de
100 watts donc des jambes de quelqu'un
qui fait un gros effort physique gros
efforts physiques et qu'une seule
personne dans la salle qui est capable
de faire ça
un gros effort physique et bien pour
autant ça ne vous développe une
puissance de 100 watts
au cours de cet effort et si je fais un
calcul analogue avec les bras par
exemple on vous en décaissé 15 tonnes de
terre dans la journée en faisant un gros
trou pour les géraniums et bien vous
allez vous rendre compte c'est pareil
que vos bras ils sont capables de
développer une puissance moyenne dans la
journée qui est dix fois inférieure à
celle de vos jambes et comme vous pouvez
le constater ils sont un peu plus petits
en général sauf chez monsieur ce soir
c'est la guerre alors maintenant on va
imaginer que vous allez utiliser
quelques machines de la vie courante
alors je vais commencer par une machine
de la vie courante que évidemment vous
avez tous utilisés dans cette salle non
j'ai découvert il n'y a pas eu il ya pas
longtemps qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont
jamais utilisé ce genre de machine qui
va regrouper données qui s'appelle un
mixeur à soupe avait un truc que vous
mettez dans la sof vous appuyez dessus
ça fait visite et vous mixez la soupe
est ce que les gens quand j'avais
utilisé un mixeur à soupe ici parce que
vous avez un moulin à légumes ou parce
que vous avez jamais fait de souffle
mais jamais faite sous ce n'est pas bien
ce dont vous utilisez un mixeur à
souffre alors votre mixeur à soupe au
moment où vous le mettez en action il va
vous voulez les légumes dans la
casserole d'accord est-ce que vous avez
une idée de la puissance moyenne d'un
mixeur à soupe
non kilowatts non quand même là la soupe
déborde quelques centaines de watts donc
vous appuyer sur l'interrupteur de votre
mixeur à soupe et vous avez quatre
cyclistes qui se mettent à pédaler pour
vous vous avez jamais fait soupe mais
vous avez quand même passer l'aspirateur
un jour non mais j'avais passé
l'aspirateur prix qui vous vivez vous
allez vous faire engueuler donc si vous
passez l'aspirateur la puissance pour
est-ce que vous avez une idée de la
puissance moyenne d'un aspirateur 500
watts et un tout petit c'est plutôt 1500
d'accord donc vous appuyez sur le bouton
de votre aspirateur et ya quinze
cyclistes qui se mettent à pédaler vous
avez déjà pris un ascenseur alors là
vous appuyez sur le bouton de
l'ascenseur il ya cinquante cyclistes
dans la carafe qui se mettent à pédaler
corps voilà quelques machines qui nous
entourent du quotidien alors maintenant
je vais en prendre une autre qui nous
est absolument indispensable aujourd'hui
je vais prendre un tracteur le tracteur
qui développe une puissance de quelques
dizaines de kilowatts un peu plus si
vous êtes céréalier dans la brousse un
peu moins si vous êtes vigne on
développe la même puissance que quelques
centaines de paires de jambes et alors
comme il ya longtemps qu'on est passé
des gens vous a dit votre s avoue
développe quand même la même puissance
que quasiment une centaine de chevaux de
trait donc vous donner un tracteur à un
agriculteur vous pouvez virer 599
agriculteurs qui avant un tract et la
charrue avec lui ou plus exactement vous
pouvez sortir des champs énormément de
gens qui n'ont strictement plus rien à y
faire
le tracteur et les usines d'engrais qui
sont également des énormes machines qui
fonctionnent pour nous sont la cause
première de l'exode rural dans les pays
qui se sont industrialisés encore la
surface cultivable n'a pas augmenté
on a pu exploiter cette surface
cultivable avec beaucoup moins de gens
parce que les machines se sont mis à
travailler à notre place en 1800 avant
les tracteurs et les engrais deux tiers
de la population active était agricoles
ce qui est une autre manière de dire que
dans le budget des ménages deux tiers de
ce qu'ils gagnent a été consacré à la
nourriture
aujourd'hui c'est 10% 'tout compris' y
compris les repas au restaurant ou en
fait vous ne payez pas la nourriture
vous payer le restaurant le service la
pub du restaurant etc nourriture aux
cacahuètes
dans l'addition à la fin donc les
tracteurs ont été une cause absolument
majeur de changement de la répartition
de la population sur le territoire
prenez maintenant un engin très en vogue
à l'époque des municipales puisque c'est
ce qui permet de promettre les
ronds-points qui arriveront à la
prochaine mandature des engins de
travaux publics et bien un engin de
travaux publics développe la même
puissance que quelques milliers de
paires de bras avant les engins de
travaux publics
et soit dit en passant les grues les
cimenteries et sert à faire construire
un logement c'était l'oeuvre d'une vie
humaine est en fait le temps d'une vie
humaine si vous rajoutiez une pièce à la
maison familiale c'était vraiment le
bout du monde
aujourd'hui pour quelques années de
salaire d'un individu l'engin de
terrassement arrive terrasse en 24
heures alors qu avec des pelles et des
pioches ça aurait pris des mois ou au
moins des semaines est derrière vous
faites construire un logement pour
quelques années de salaire c'est un truc
qui n'est jamais arrivé dans l'histoire
des hommes et on doit ça ou machine
prenez un camion il [ __ ] comme
quelques milliers de fois les jambes de
son conducteur et grâce aux camions nous
avons fait les villes si demain matin je
supprime la totalité des camions en
france l'essentiel des habitants des
villes se mettent à mourir de faim parce
que vous n'avez pas la possibilité de
transporter à dos d'homme
la nourriture qui doit arriver
quotidiennement dans les villes un
camion sur trois en france transportent
quelque chose qui se mange donc si je
supprime les camions demain matin donc
si je supprime le pétrole demain matin
eh bien les habitants des villes se
mettent à mourir de faim déjà les
agriculteurs ont plus les moyens de
produire puisque les tracteurs peu plus
avancées et les habitants des villes ne
peut plus être nourris et maintenant je
vais prendre à laminoir pas très loin de
là où nous sommes vus de paris je suis
désolé s'est vu de paris pas très loin
un horrible propre aux jacobins de
parisiens pédant et insupportable je
prends deux laminoirs de fos-sur-mer
m'accorderez que vu de paris cependant
trop loin quand même
eh bien le laminoir de fos-sur-mer lui
il a la même puissance que la totalité
de la puissance musculaire des bras de
la région la plus peuplée de france
c'est à dire de l'île de france donc si
demain matin je supprimais le laminoir
de fos-sur-mer et que je remplaçais sa
part des franciliens utilisant la force
de leurs muscles pour taper sur des
tôles pour me laminer les tôles de la
même manière
eh bien je devrais prendre toute l'île
de france et lui donner un marteau et
rien que pour remplacer le laminoir de
fos sur mer c'est à dire une machine
parmi les dizaines de millions qu'on
utilise et qui nous rend un service qui
est de la ville et de l'acier donc là
vous avez des exemples de quelques
machines qu'on utilise et en fait je le
redis des machines qu'on utilise y en a
des millions quand vous vous êtes
habillé ce matin puisque personne n'est
tout nu dans cette salle vous avez
utilisé plaint de machines sans vous en
rendre compte vous avez utilisé sans
vous en rendre compte les machines qui
ont planté le coton qui ont récolté le
coton qui ont filé le coton qui ont
tissé le coton qui ont atteint le coton
qui ont transporté le coton
si vous avez des fibres synthétiques sur
vous vous avez utilisé indirectement à
bout de plateforme pétrolière et un
vapocraqueur et une raffinerie et des
extrudeur et enfin plein plein plein de
machines vous avez utilisé simplement en
enfilant des vêtements ce matin d'accord
donc nous vivons aujourd'hui dans un
monde de machines et un truc très
important et j'insisterai dessus c'est
un monde dans lequel la production est
assurée par les machines corp en fait il
ya longtemps que les gens travaillent
plus ou très peu en train travailler
dans cette salle moi non plus mon métier
est d'enseigner c'est pas un travail je
veux dire c'est juste cause et quoi à
l'époque où on devait vraiment
transformé de la matière n'avait c'est
pas un travail aujourd'hui le vrai
travail c'était à fabriquer nos
vêtements ce qu'on mange et c'est assez
des machines qui s'en occupe nous on
fait plus sens tout ce qu'on a besoin de
faire nous c'est d'arbitrer la
production des machines
c'est ça les emplois de service c'est
pour ça qu'il ya énormément d'emplois de
services dans les pays qui sont sous
perfusion d'énergie de façon très
importante parce que du coup il ya
énormément de flux à gérer extrêmement
compliqué s'il n'y a pas je vais prendre
un exemple puisque nous sommes dans les
facs de droit si je supprime l'industrie
de la fabrication des voitures
je supprime tous les banquiers qui
finance des voitures neuves
je finance tous les assureurs
je supprime tous les assureurs pardon
qui assure les voitures neuves
je supprime également tous les juristes
qui ont besoin de me faire des contrats
de vente pour les voitures
ce que nous sommes dans une fac de droit
je supprime au bout d'un moment tous les
juristes qui s'occupe des procès pour
les gens qui ont des accidents voiture
oui donc en fait les dire que les
emplois de service sont détachables de
l'industrie c'est pareil les emplois de
service ils sont raccrochés à des flux
physiques alors les machines que nous
utilisons aujourd'hui qu'ils mangent
leur enquête particulière donc l'énergie
croquettes pour machines elles ont
permis de démultiplier la puissance
musculaire des hommes par un facteur de
sang dit autrement la force productive
des machines
aujourd'hui sur terre c'est celle de
1400 milliards d'êtres humains
ces 1400 milliards d'êtres humains
je vais vous dire encore autrement le
mode de vie que nous avons en moyenne
sur terre est le même que s'il n'y avait
pas de machine et qu'on avait deux en
esclaves par personne chacun alors ça
c'est la moyenne mondiale comme les
français consomment beaucoup plus que la
moyenne mondiale
en france c'est pas 200 esclaves par
personne qu'on a c'est plutôt six ans
donc ce que je suis en train de vous
dire en vous rappelant ce que c'est
l'énergie
c'est une vérité politique indicible
c'est que le smic à harvey comme un
nabab considérablement mieux qu'un baron
du moyen-âge considérablement moins
élevés alors évidemment il est pas
content parce que des gens comme moi et
bernard arnaud lyon-caen mieux que lui
mais le smicard et le retraité
aujourd'hui vit comme un nabab là comme
un nabab grâce à l'énergie qui a permis
de mettre en oeuvre des machines
totalement surpuissante qui nous assure
la totalité de ce que tout pour
retrouver pour pas cher l'un des
avantages des machines par rapport aux
animaux de trait aux esclaves d'antan en
plus c'est que elle nous libère la
totalité de l'espace en surface parce
qu'à l'époque où nous avions des animaux
de trait 40 à 50 % des surfaces de
valeur est réservée alors certes on
finissait par les bouffer à la fin enfin
quand même
on devait quand même les garder en vie
le temps que ça nous servait et quand on
utilisait des esclaves c'est pas votre
esclave qui n'a pas à manger y meurt et
dont vous perdez votre esclave un peu
ballot donc il fallait aussi avoir de
quoi les nourrir les machines des temps
modernes mange du sous sol c'est génial
en plus elle l'hiver tout l'espace en
surface et du reste dans les énergies
renouvelables qui proviennent de la
biomasse vous voyez bien ressurgir ce
conflit d'usagé des sols où chacun veut
l'espace pour qui manger qui un usage
énergétique etc
qu y avoir de la forêt parce qu'il faut
la filière bois etc
on voit revenir tout ça alors cet
arbitrage à ce pardon ce rôle de
l'énergie malheureusement est totalement
invisible dans l'économie que nous avons
apprises à l'école et l'économie que les
étudiants dans cette salle apprennent à
l'école c'est totalement invisible parce
qu'au moment où on théorise l'économie
classique ya deux siècles on se dit que
on va simplement se limiter à ce qui est
rare et ce qui est limite ans il ya deux
siècles sur la production c'est pas les
ressources
il y en a autant qu'on veut je vous
rappelle qu'il ya deux siècles a tout
juste commencé la colonisation des états
unis on sait pas que l'antarctique
existe et on n'a pas la moindre idée de
la totalité de ce qui se passe sur
l'océan donc il ya deux siècles le monde
est infini en première approximation
par contre ce n'est pas du tout un fini
c'est le nombre de gens qui peuvent
travailler et le capital humain déjà
accumulé essentiellement les terres
mises en culture et donc à ce moment
quand les économistes de l'époque
commence à théoriser l'économie 10
massie on se limite à ce qu'il ait pas
si on part donc si on regarde juste les
limitant pour la production
on va prendre le facteur humain le
facteur naturel on l'oubli c'est pas la
peine il a strictement aucune importance
et donc les économistes de l'époque
10 et voilà jean baptiste s'est par
exemple qui le dit explicitement la
nature est gratuite
les ressources naturelles sont gratuites
jamais dans les prix vous ne verrez le
fait que la nature a mis des ressources
à la disposition
j'avais donc l'économie vous apprenez à
l'école elle vous dit que pour alimenter
un système productif
vous avez besoin de gens qui travaillent
vous avez besoin de capital humain et si
vous avez du capital humain et des gens
qui travaillent le supermarché rempli
alors lieux n'ont donc plus vous mettez
de gens au travail et plus vous avez des
banques est sympathique et plus le
supermarché se remplit
alors arrive je ne sais pas qui ils
ingénieurs ou le simple à simple
personne le paysan de bon sens il vous
dit oui enfin pour avoir le supermarché
rempli à droite là ce que vous avez ça
se touche ça contient des atomes vos
atom faut bien les avoir payés par ce
qui va constituer les vêtements les
lunettes et les téléphones s'est
constitué de matières cette matière faut
bien la prendre quelques parts et à ce
moment ce quelque part ça s'appelle des
ressources
tous les produits que vous avez autour
de vous tous autant qu'ils sont ne sont
que des ressources naturelles qui ont
été transformés par notre activité
rien d'autre d'accord de la paire de
chaussettes aux destroyer c'est que des
ressources naturelles transformé par
notre activité
donc c'est des ressources qu'il faut
transformer et il faut avoir une
capacité de transformation pour ses
ressources c'est précisément ça le
travail et ce travail aujourd'hui et
fourni très marginalement par les hommes
est principalement par les machines
donc le système productif que nous avons
cédé machine alimentée par d'énergie qui
consomment des ressources et qui font
tout ce que nous avons en face et donc
je le redis on est juste là pour gérer
le système
donc on est là pour fournir des
comptables pour le supermarché des
vendeurs pour le supermarché les
publicitaires pour le supermarché et
c'est tout sauf ce que vous trouvez
vraiment dans un supermarché
c'est à dire des trucs à acheter et
quand vous regardez les services ses
bases est exactement de la même manière
vous ne faites pas un salon de coiffure
sans que vous ayez les lacs et les
cosmétiques de fabricants que je ne
nommerai pas sans que vous ayez les
sièges parce qu'un salon coiffure dans
lequel vous restez debout ya pas
beaucoup de clients sans que vous ayez
construite salon de coiffure avec de la
matière parce que sinon l'hiver il ya
personne parce qu'on s'appelle et il
pleut et c'est donc et sans que vous
ayez les tondeuses que donc même pour
les services
en fait vous n'avez pas un service qui
échappent à cette règle tous les
services demandent aussi des flux
matériel tous on peut représenter le
capital dans cette représentation qui
est simplement une boucle interne c'est
à dire c'est des trucs qu'ils se
détruisent pas quand on s'en sert
typiquement cet immeuble normalement
sinon s'il s'écroule quand on s'en sert
ça fait un scandale dans la presse
ce que vous voyez apparaître sur ce
graphique c'est d'autres facteurs
limitants au système
il y en a un premier qui est que si les
machines non plus leur croquettes pour
machines qui s'appelle de l'énergie elle
s'arrête de travailler donc elle se met
pas en grève parce que elle réclame une
augmentation juste s'arrête de
travailler et si les machines s'arrête
de travailler là
duction s'arrête aussi donc je reprends
l'exemple de mes camions si vous avez
une flotte de camions avec des
conducteurs parfaitement prêt à conduire
et un banquier parfaitement prêt à vous
financez et pas d'essence avec dans les
camions production de la flotte de
camions et l'uil voilà et de même que
dans la rade de toulon
si on doit ressortir à la rame les
bateaux militaires modernes je pense que
ça va être un peu difficile d'aller
faire la guerre
donc vous voyez bien que l'énergie est
un facteur limitant de la production
parce que c'est un facteur limitant de
la mise en action des machines les
ressources peuvent également être un
facteur limitant pour rester dans la
méditerranée s'il ya moins de poissons à
pêcher
il ya évidemment moins de produits de la
pêche ce qui peut créer soit dit en
passant quelques tensions
donc vous avez ici encore une fois deux
autres facteurs limitants qui peuvent
exister dans le système
alors aujourd'hui à l'échelle mondiale
il s'applique pas encore à plein mais
localement ou régionalement
ça a commencé et ils se trouvent bonne
nouvelle pour nous que l'europe et la
méditerranée sont aux avant-postes de
ces limitations qui ont commencé à
s'exercer je vais y venir n'a pas
londres
ici vous avez une reconstituion une
reconstitution pardon de la production
économique mondiale depuis la naissance
de monsieur jésus christ je suis désolé
excellent et un peu stupide
donc il sait pas que le calendrier
romain commence à 1 donc il va commencer
à zéro il faudrait que je pense à
corriger ça mais vous avez ici dans
cette reconstitution alors pendant
longtemps les hommes n'ont pas une
machine sont éventuellement des outils
ils ont pas une machine
donc le pib est essentiellement une
fonction de la population à cette époque
là la population augmente pas beaucoup
donc le pib augmente pas beaucoup
jusqu'au déploiement à large échelle des
machines sur terre c'est à dire le début
de la révolution industrielle le pib
augmente pas beaucoup non plus il faut
qu'ils commencent à augmenter un peu
mais popp a vraiment beaucoup et puis là
dessus arrive le moteur à combustion
interne et la machine à vapeur est alors
l'art à l'oubli on vous explique qu'on
va sauver les retraites avec la
croissance perpétuelle
nous voyons arriver dans le langage des
économistes un truc qui est quand même
une vaste blague qui s'appelle la
croissance structurelle de long terme
enfin je veux dire comment est ce qu'on
peut dire des trucs pareils sans être
bourré l'emprise de stupéfiants
croissance structurelle de longueur
évidemment que sur une planète terre qui
fait désespérément treize mille
kilomètres de diamètre qui faisait
treize mille kilomètres de diamètre ya
deux siècles qui fera toujours 13 mille
kilomètres de diamètre dans deux siècles
il n'y aura jamais de croissance
structurelle le long terme il ya une
parenthèse de l'humanité avec de la
croissance mais c'est pas structurelles
de long terme et je peux vous dire que
ça va pas durer jusqu'au moment où les
plus jeunes dans cette salle vont
prendre leur retraite et c'est pas du
tout sûr que ça dure jusqu'au moment où
moi je meurs
alors pour le moment ça dure donc sature
très très bien vous avez ici quelque
chose qui est la contrepartie logique de
ce que je viens de vous raconter dans un
monde de machines vous regardez la
quantité d'énergie utilisée alors par
les hommes par les machines parce que là
aussi est supercherie de langage vous ne
consommez pas d'énergie la seule énergie
que vous vous consommez c'est quand vous
mangez un plat de tripes qui est
délicieux par ailleurs où une portion de
carottes râpées ou que vous faites
chauffer au soleil mais c'est la seule
façon que vous avez de conserver de
l'énergie
vous ne buvez pas de pétrole je vous le
déconseille c'est vraiment pas terrible
et vous ne mangez pas de charbon sur le
charbon qu'on mangeait pour les
flatulences mais c'est pas vraiment pour
l'énergie donc nous ne concevons pas
d'énergie c'est pas vrai quand on dit
qu'on consomme de l'énergie en fait
c'est elle
mickey dans fantasia on met en route des
machines c'est ça qu'on fait c'est
magique et c'est ça qu'on fait donc la
quantité d'énergie n'est pas utilisé par
les hommes elle est utilisée par les
machines et si vous représentez la
quantité d'énergie en fait ça ne
représente que le parc de machines en
fonctionnement
c'est ça qui représente est donc ici sur
cette courbe qui démarre en 1965
chaque année représentant
un point et qui va jusqu'en 2018 ce que
ça dit c'est que la quantité de machines
en service vous donne très exactement le
pib on a des constantes
donc en fait le fameux pib qui doit
croître pour payer les retraites assurer
la baisse du chômage etc
monsieur macron ni peut strictement rien
parce que il ne peut rien sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
qui permet de mettre en route le parc de
machines mondial ça se passe ailleurs
que chez lui il peut un petit quelque
chose sur la fraction de cette énergie
qu'on va réussir à avoir chez nous un
petit quelque chose il peut un gros
quelque chose sur la seule énergie qu'on
maîtrise domestiquement qui est
l'hydroélectricité et d'une certaine
manière le nucléaire parce que le seul
truc qu'on importe c'est l'uranium mais
c'est passé passer par des grosses
quantités
mais pour le reste bas il est pris dans
la barque mondiale c'est pas lui qui
produit le pétrole c'est pas lui qui
produit le gaz c'est pas lui qui prend
une chambre et comme l'essentiel de
l'énergie qu'on utilise aujourd'hui sur
terre et fossiles à 2 81% voilà le drame
des négociations climat j'y reviendrai
un peu plus tard c'est que vous ne savez
pas aujourd'hui augmenter le pib sans
augmenter le co2 et inversement
nous ne saurons pas limiter le
réchauffement climatique sans baisser le
pib
on s'en rapproche rsa alors la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il finira par baisser
de toute façon pas la bonne ou la
mauvaise je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
la nouvelle c'est qu'il finira par
baisser de toute façon mais parce qu'il
est tributaire de ressources qui sont
épuisables
mais il faut bien voir qu'aujourd'hui la
question du changement climatique c'est
gérer un conflit d'objectif monstrueux
que nous avons à tous les étages entre
ce qui est notre but depuis des siècles
c'est à dire accroître la quantité de
biens et de services dont on peut
disposer et faire baisser les émissions
de co2 d'accord il ya un conflit
d'objectif frontale entre ces deux trucs
là est donc temps que l'europe chercheur
à la croissance ce qui est aujourd'hui
son objectif parce que dans l'article 3
du traité de lisbonne
il est écrit l'europe vise la croissance
c'est écrit noir sur blanc
donc nous avons une constitution en
europe qui nous dit notre objectif c'est
la croissance d'une des rares
constitution de pays à mon avis qui dit
ça eh bien tant qu on visera la
croissance on ne pourra pas avoir de
baisse des émissions de co2
autrement que via des processus qui nous
demande pas qui nous demande pas notre
avis alors vous allez voir qu'il ya déjà
un en europe mais c'est un processus qui
nous demande pas notre avis donc
l'histoire des hommes depuis deux
siècles
c'est il ya des combustibles fossiles
sous terre ils sont gratuits
il est tombé sur la tête depuis quand
l'essence est gratuite si si le pétrole
est gratuit car le pétrole s'est formé
comme toutes les ressources naturelles
sans que qui que ce soit dans cette
salle ne payent le moins de centimes
donc le vent se forment sans vous payer
le moindre centime
le soleil brille sans vous payer le
moindre centime le pétrole s'est formé
sans qu'on paye le moindre centime
il ya personne dans la salle qui a payé
le moindre centime pour que le pétrole
se forme sur terre quand ce qui coûte
dans tous les cas de figure c'est le
travail humain et les rentes humaines
pour aller chercher la ressource donc
pour le vent faut payer des gens pour
construire des éoliennes allait les
mettre en place etc et faut payer la
rente c'est à dire faut louer son champ
à l'agriculteur en lui disant voilà une
version axée sur une version annexe est
temps de les exproprier pour le pétrole
c'est pareil il faut payer des gens pour
aller le chercher il faut payer des
rentes c'est à dire celui qui est assis
dessus parce qu'il a eu la bonne idée et
la version atex et d'exproprier donc
vous y allez avec les chars et les
avions est dit pousse toi de là que je
m'y mette pétrole est à moi mais c'est
dans tous les cas de figure que des
revenus humain que vous payez quand vous
payez l'énergie ne payez pas la nature
qui ne vous envoie pas de facture
j'avais donc ces combustibles brûlant
ils ont la possibilité d'actionner un
parc de machines qui nous a permis de
transformer tout ce qui nous est tombé
sous la main et donc de faire en
quantité croissante des objets de toute
nature
et comme les machines se sont mises à
travailler à deux places dont on a du
temps libre
alors à quoi on affecte ce temps libre à
se mettre entre guillemets travailler
plus tard
mais quelles différences pourquoi est ce
qu'on appelle travail le fait de passer
deux étudiants qui est assis derrière un
bureau à apprendre des trucs à
consultants qui est assis derrière un
bureau à apprendre des trucs comme en
conventionnel 1 passe et 2 étudiants
s'est assis à une chaise
assis sur une chaise pardon en train
d'écouter quelqu'un qui cause et vous
allez derrière devenir employé de bureau
à l'accueil de la caisse nationale de la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie et
vous allez être assis derrière un bureau
à écouter des gens qui cause
quelle différence donc dans un cas on
appelle ça travaille dans l'autre cas on
appelle ça études
en fait c'est pas et physiquement
d'accord donc en fait on a du temps
libre
alors on l'a fait que tu as quoi ce
temps libre à être assis derrière un
bureau voilà alors ça peut s'appeler la
retraite ça peut s'appeler les études ça
s'appelle le week end ça s'appelle les
35 heures ça s'appelle les vacances
voilà tout ça c'est une contrepartie de
l'abondance énergétique donc les
revendications conjointe de la cgt et du
medef et de l'ufc que choisir c'est
l'énergie ce qui a fait votre pouvoir
d'achat
c'est l'énergie ce qui a fait les villes
parce que les gens n'avaient plus besoin
d'être au plus près de la ressource à la
campagne c'est l'énergie ce qui a fait
la mondialisation c'est l'énergie
tout ça est évidemment transitoire parce
que le pétrole le gaz et le charbon
seront transitoires sur terre mais ce
qui a fait tout ça c'est l'énergie est
la contrepartie monétaire de ce tout ça
est bien s'appelle le pib donc dans ce
conte de fées on a deux forces de
frottement que monsieur jean baptiste
say n'avait pas vu mais des gens pas
loin de son époque avait déjà commencé à
voir puisque l'effet de serre est connu
depuis joseph fourier en 1826 c'est le
changement climatique à laval et un
goulet d'étranglement à l'amont qui est
la disponibilité en combustibles
fossiles on va rentrer un peu dans le
détail sur les deux à l'amont les
combustibles fossiles portent bien leur
nom puisqu'il s'agit de possible alors
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un fossile c1
reste reste sédimenter de quelque chose
qui a vécu il ya longtemps encore vous
avez des coquilles d'ammonites et c'est
alors un fossile particulier si le
pétrole le pétrole est un restes
fossiles de micro algues et de plancton
ayant vécu comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ce graphique n'importe quand il ya 50
millions d'années et il ya 400 millions
d'années et les restes biologiques de
cette vie ont été sédimenté dans la
croûte terrestre par la tectonique des
plaques cuit par la géothermie et ça a
fini par vous donner du pétrole et du
gaz
qui sait dans les bons cas de figure
accumulée dans des roches poreuses
typiquement du calcaire éventuellement
du grès éventuellement des sables pour
faire ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un
réservoir de pétrole
un réservoir de pétrole soit dit en
passant c'est pas comme le réservoir de
votre voiture
l'idée qui se remplit en une minute ça
met des dizaines de millions d'années à
s'emplir et ça met des dizaines d'années
à se vider c'est une roche g une roche
imprégnés d'huile
donc vous voyez que les complicités le
charbon pardon s'est formé en une seule
passe il ya à partir de ya 300 millions
d'années avec des fougères qui ont
poussé à l'ère du charbon le carbonifère
donc les combustibles fossiles c'est
tout-à-fait renouvelable si vous avez le
temps d'attendre 300 millions d'années
si vous n'avez pas le temps d'attendre
300 millions d'années on va dire que
c'est pas trés renouvelables est en fait
vous tapez dans un stock à l'échelle des
temps historiques on va considérer qu'il
est donnée une fois pour toutes d'accord
on qu'à l'échelle des temps historiques
quelques siècles on va considérer que du
pétrole
il y en a une quantité donnée une fois
pour toutes on peut ne pas savoir où il
est en fait on sait de mieux en mieux
brûler mais on peut ne pas savoir où il
est et c mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à
cause de sa durée de formation
il ya une quantité de départ au début de
la partie de monopoly qui est donnée une
fois pour toutes en fait on sait de
mieux en mieux willem mais je pourrais
revenir sur les questions à partir du
moment où vous tapez dans un stock de
départ qui est donnée une fois pour
toutes vous êtes d'accord avec moi que
il n'est pas possible d'avoir une
extraction annuel en provenance de ce
stock qui augmente indéfiniment
d'accord vous pouvez pas avoir chaque
année plus de pétrole que l'année
précédente et ça jusqu'à la nuit des
temps parce que ça voudrait dire que le
stock est infinie vous ne pouvez même
pas à avoir un stock de départ qui à
part dont une production annuelle qui
soit perpétuellement constante à nouveau
ça voudrait dire que le stock est
infinie alors si chaque année vous êtes
capable d'avoir la même chose que
l'année précédente et ce jusqu'à la nuit
des temps c'est que vous avez un stock
infinie en fait les mathématiques vous
permet de démontrer chose que je fais
des montrer à mes étudiants quand j'ai
décidé d'être désagréable que en pareil
cas vous n'avez qu'une seule fois vous
avez trois conditions aux limites
pardon que votre production est tenu de
respecter la première c'est que si vous
remontez suffisamment loin dans le temps
sa part de zéro pour cent c'est facile à
vérifier en ce qui concerne le pétrole
si je remonte suffisamment loin dans le
temps il ya un moment à l'époque des
dinosaures il ya pas d'homme donc pour
sortir le pétrole due
pétrole à sortir donc le la production à
québec
si vous allez suffisamment loin dans le
temps ça redeviendra nul est entre les
deux vous allez passer par un maximum
absolu à l'extraction
c'est à dire un sommet historique qui ne
sera jamais dépassé et derrière lequel
vous auriez un déclin alors ce sommet
historique a coutume d'être appelé le
pic soit dit en passant cette notion de
pic s'applique au pétrole mais ça
s'applique aux minerais de cuivre au
vanadium autant talent ou chrome os
cobalt au nickel à n'importe quoi qui
sort de la croûte terrestre exactement
pour les mêmes raisons parce que vous
n'avez pas de régénération en continu
d'atomes de cobalt et d'atomes de cuivre
et d'atomes d'aluminium et d'atomes
d'argent de toute façon toutes les
ressources minérales passe moins un jour
par un pic en ce qui concerne leur
extraction de la croûte terrestre
pendant longtemps alors quand j'ai connu
pascal donc en 2002 j'étais un peu comme
le professeur tournesol de tapin la
balade et compan nuls en dix ans le pic
bientôt le pic bientôt alors maintenant
j'ai reçu un allié de poids parce que
c'est pas le pic bientôt c'est le pic
est derrière nous vous avez ici un
document qui aurait mérité un peu plus
de publicité que les sextoys de benjamin
illégaux enfin c'est en 2018 sais pas
s'il est déjà et sextape donc qui est
sorti en 2010 8 en décembre 2018 et ce
document vous dit que en ce qui concerne
le pétrole conventionnel et je vais
détailler un tout petit peu après de
quoi il s'agit c'est à dire tout ce qui
n'est pas les sables bitumineux du
canada vous savez ces exploitations dans
les mines à ciel ouvert là où oracle du
sable a prédit de bitume pour en faire
un pétrole de synthèse et tout ce qui
n'est pas le pétrole qu'on appelle de
schiste aux états unis alors le pétrole
de schiste en fait c'est du pétrole qui
s'obtient en fracturant des roches mères
on devrait l'appeler du pétrole de roche
mère et c'est ce fameux pétrole qu'on
obtient par fracturation hydraulique et
bien si j'excepte ces deux sous
ensembles du pétrole la totalité du
reste de la production mondiale est en
déclin depuis 2008 alors 2008
s'il ya un banquier dans la salle ça
doit lui rappeler un petit quelque chose
il ya un lien direct entre ce qui s'est
passé dans le monde financier en 2008
2009 et ce à un lien direct parce que le
pétrole s'arrête de croître et se met à
décroître
du coup la quantité de conquête pour
machine s'arrête de croître et se met à
décroître pour les machines qui servent
à transporter et dont je vais vous
montrer dans pas longtemps qu'elles sont
les plus limitantes dans le système
économique mondial
du coup le pib s'arrête de croître et il
ya même des zones dans lequel il
commence à décroître et du coup la
pyramide de ponzi que nous avons créés
sur la dette depuis le premier choc
pétrolier qui est aussi un processus
énergétique est attaqué par un pib qui
décroît et à ce moment le truc vole en
éclats donc ce que nous avons eu en 2008
2009 c'est une crise énergétique et
cette crise énergétique entre guillemets
est là pour durer comme je vais vous le
montrer donc c'est pas une crise qui
derrière se résorbe
c'est le début d'un changement de
paradigme et ce changement de paradigme
inclura par exemple que si la part de
l'armée dans le pib n'augmente pas votre
budget va baisser de manière
structurelle avec le reste de ce que
sera le pib alors cette évolution elle a
été particulièrement ressentie en europe
vous avez ici la quantité de pétrole
dont dispose des européens c'est à dire
les machines situées en europe
cette quantité de pétrole est subdivisé
en deux compartiments vous avez ce que
produit la mer du nord dont vous voyez
qu'elle est passée par son pic en 2000
de façon parfaitement nette
est ce qu'on importe est ce qu'on
apporte a permis de compenser le déclin
de la mer du nord jusqu'en 2006 et vous
voyez qu'à partir de 2006 ça s'arrête
et ça se met à décliner également donc
la quantité de croquettes pour camions
pour bateaux très accessoirement pour
hélicoptères et pour avions dont nous
disposons en europe a commencé à
décliner à partir de 2006 c'est
exactement pareil aux états unis je
voulais sommes pas avec les courbes mais
c'est exactement pareil dans toute la
zone ocde à cela l'europe rajoute des
particularités régionales qui vont
également dans le même sens
l'europe utilise également du gaz pour
mettre en route d'autres machines le gaz
vient essentiellement de la mer du nord
parce que le gaz est en gazon
merci dictionnaire il se trouve qu'il
est beaucoup plus mal commode à
transporter
sur le longue distance que le pétrole
qui liquide et donc le gaz à la
différence du pétrole n'est pas une
énergie mondiale c'est une énergie
régionales le gars se transporte bien
quand vous avez un tuyau qui va d'un
producteur à un consommateur et qu'on
change pas de producteurs et
consommateurs entourent ou en cours de
route d'accord donc le gaz se fait
l'objet et vous avez des pays pour
lesquels le gazoduc est un truc qui
coûte tellement cher qu'ils préfèrent
importer d'un côté du pays est exportée
de l'autre côté du pays c'est par
exemple le cas de l'iran donc vous avez
du gaz en europe qui est essentiellement
issus de la mer du nord et vous voyez
qu'en 2005 la mer du nord passe son pic
plouffe se mit à décliner et à ce moment
instantanément la quantité de gaz
disponible en europe s'arrête de croître
et se mit à décroître
après nous avons également du charbon en
europe
or il se trouve que le charbon lui il a
passé son pic dans les années 60 a bien
avant que le climat devient un problème
parce que ça fait deux siècles qu'on
tape dans nos mines de charbon savait
que la grande bretagne est le premier
pays à avoir connu un essor industriel
grâce à ses mines de charbon puis
derrière ça a suivi la france
l'allemagne du reste on s'est souvent
chicane et les français les allemands à
cause du charbon et de l'acier
ça a été l'objet de mettre quelques
militaires au travail et donc depuis les
années 60 la quantité de charbon de
charbon disponibles en europe décline et
elle ne décline pas doucement elle
décline extrêmement rapidement parce que
oui sur cette courbe serrée faut la
production là sur cette série ça démarre
quand 80 ne peut importe et la
consommation
est ce que vous voyez c'est que quand la
production décline la consommation
décline aussi parce que le charbon se
transporte pas encore plus mal que le
gaz c'est un pont vers solide et donc
c'est extrêmement compliqué de
transporter des grandes quantités de
charbon sur de longues distances
il ya un charbon avec lequel on fait
bien ça c'est le charbon métallurgique
parce qu'il vaut très cher mais par
contre le charbon vapeur celui qu'on
utilise pour faire d'électricité ce qui
est soit dit en passant est
l'utilisation dominante du charbon dans
le monde dont les deux tiers du charbon
extrait d'une mine de charbon dans le
monde servent à alimenter des centrales
électriques et bien le charbon se
transporte mal sur de longues distances
quand il vaut pas très cher ce qui est
le cas de l'essentiel du charbon alors
si j'empile toutes les énergies fossiles
qui sont en contraction en europe voilà
ce que ça donne
ici vous avez la quantité de croquettes
pour machines à part européen depuis
oui ça c'est les trente glorieuses
ra lovely de plus en plus de croquettes
pour machines par européen donc de plus
en plus de machines par européen donc de
plus en plus de productions par européen
c'est le moment où les cheveux blancs
dans cette salle payent leurs pavillons
voient leurs revenus augmenter de 5% par
an et c'est que du bonheur
c'est l'énergie qui a fait ça d'accord
c'est pas mes 68 c'est vraiment
l'énergie qui a fait ça après vous avez
une deuxième période après les chocs
pétroliers ou ce que vous voyez c'est
que la quantité de croquettes pour
machines par personne cesse d'augmenter
en europe est en fait dans toute la zone
ocde c'est ça les chocs pétroliers
sait on passe d'une période où l'énergie
par personne ce terre la quantité de
machines en service par personne
augmenter rapidement à une période où ça
s'arrête d'augmenter et donc la
production par personnes s'arrêtent
d'augmenter et donc la consommation
c'est à dire le pouvoir d'achat par
personnes s'arrêtent d'augmenter
rapidement c'est pas du à l'incurie des
politiques à ce moment là c'est dû au
fait que la générosité des puits de
pétrole n'était plus la même
l'incurie des politiques a été de ne pas
le comprendre et de ne pas le gérer
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de dire à partir
de maintenant ceinture ils ont dit non
non on va continuer à distribuer autant
qu'avant il ya pas de problème on
trouvera de l'argent dans les caisses
plus tard sauf que plus tard il ya pas
eu plus de pétrole
il ya pas eu plus d'argent dans les
caisses et 20 t on à démarrer une
pyramide de ponzi à partir de ce moment
là qui s'appelle la dette et puis arrive
2006 et alors là 2006 c'est début de la
tendance inverse
alors évidemment les tendances il ya des
à-coups comme vous le pouvez le voir
mais ses débuts de la tendance inverse
c'est à dire début de la contraction de
l'énergie par européen c'est-à-dire de
la baisse du parc de machines en
fonctionnement par un européen c'est à
dire de la baisse structurelle de la
production par personne et donc de
quelque chose qui va ressembler à une
récession structurelles alors pour le
moment on a un artefact comptable qui
nous masquer un peu ce processus qui est
l'inflation des actifs tous ceux d'entre
vous dans cette salle qui ont un peu
d'immobilier le savent mais donc vous
avez le prix tous les actifs qui
augmente les actions l'immobilier les
oeuvres d'art la terre agricole les
forêts enfin des cartes qui s'achète en
ce moment crack la valeur augmente
et comme le pib des le calcul du pib ne
développe pas ce processus là on a
l'impression que pib continue
d'augmenter mais en fait le pib vrai les
tables et chaises et les mètres carrés
ça n'augmente plus et ça a même commencé
à s'éroder légèrement depuis 2007
et quand vous regardez la contrepartie
économique de cette affaire voilà le
taux de croissance du pib par personne
en europe depuis 65 ans depuis soixante
même
donc ça c'est les trente glorieuses
encore une fois les cheveux blancs dans
cette salle vivent une époque bénie
puis les croquettes pour machines
n'augmente plus on a les trente piteuses
or le pib par personne continue
d'augmenter mais beaucoup moins vite
c'est un l'efficacité des machines qui
augmente un peu de la dette et
l'inflation des actifs qui commence et 3
vous avez après 2006 alors là où on est
carrément un taux de croissance quasi
nulle en europe depuis cette époque là
mais nous sommes en europe dans un
marché qui est libre à l'intérieur des
frontières européennes
alors là tout ce qu'ils ont fait un peu
d'électricité dans cette salle le savent
quand vous avez des électrons qui
peuvent circuler librement et que vous
avez une différence de potentiel quelque
part qu'est ce qui se passe ou créer un
courant qu'est ce qui se passe en europe
dans une europe où le pib en moyenne
n'augmente plus avec des grosses
différences de revenus entre l'est et
l'ouest et où les gens et les capitaux
peuvent circuler librement
ça serait équilibre donc les industriels
de l'ouest mettent leur usine à l'est et
les travailleurs de l'est passe à
l'ouest est alors à ce moment vous
demander aux grands bretons s'ils sont
contents et les rangs bretons vous dise
n'ont laissé que les premiers de la
série
l'europe telle qu'elle est construite
aujourd'hui avec la libre circulation
des personnes et des marchandises à
l'intérieur d'une zone où on ne peut pas
mettre de force de frottement alors
qu'il ya de moins en moins d'argent
c'est évident que les tensions vont
augmenter alors je ne suis pas en train
de vous dire que je souhaite le retour
des guerres sur le sol européen
mais en attendant on est en train de
mettre en route une tectonique des
plaques qui à l'évidence va finir par
provoquer des craquements c'est
absolument évident d'accord il va se
passer des choses
ça va ça va être violent dans l'attelage
européen de manière croissante avec le
temps qui passe
alors presque je vous parle du pétrole
tentait plus parce que je le disais dans
tous les croquettes pour machines dont
on dispose c'est celle là qui sont le
plus les 80
vous avez ici deux courbes qui sont non
pas une preuve mais la traduction
logique ou la conséquence logique de ce
que je vous ai raconté
juste avant sur le facteur un à deux
sens entre la puissance des hommes et la
puissance des machines lacombe en rouge
vous donne la variation de la quantité
de pétrole qui sort des puits sur terre
alors envoyé avant les chocs pétroliers
cette quantité de pétrole augmente très
rapidement 8% par an c'était juste pas
de nabeul c'est pour ça qu'on a eu les
chocs pétroliers
c'était juste pas tenable encore
physiquement ça pouvait pas durer
et puis au moment des chocs pétroliers
vous avez une correction extrêmement
violent de ce taux de croissance qui
passe même en négatif pendant un certain
nombre d'années et en bleu vous avez la
variation du pib par personne
ce que vous voyez c'est que depuis les
chocs pétroliers c'est à dire que depuis
qu'on a gratté tout ce qu'on pouvait
gratter sur l'efficacité des machines
qui concerne le pétrole est bien la
quantité de pétrole dont on dispose
j'ai bien la quantité est l'élément
directeur de l'économie mondiale la
variation du pib par personne reflète
très exactement la variation de la
quantité de pétrole qui sont des [ __ ]
très exactement
donc là vous avez le meilleur indicateur
avancé de la variation du pib dans le
monde
regardez la variation de la quantité de
pétrole disponible et vous aurez la
variation du pib mondial
comment évolue le pétrole en ce moment
et bien voilà la quantité de pétrole qui
sort des puits depuis 1973
donc là vous voyez le ralentissement dû
au choc pétrolier pardon est ce que vous
voyez c'est que de 2005 à 2010 ça
n'augmente plus c'est ça qui a déclenché
la crise des subprimes mais ce que vous
voyez c'est que depuis quelques années
ça n'augmente plus non plus et qu'est ce
qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment malgré la création monétaire
absolument massif que nous avons le pib
ne repart pas on voit apparaître des
taux négatifs
les placements de l'argent deviennent un
peu partout inférieures à l'inflation
on est en train de voir des trucs très
bizarre à paraître dans l'économie en
fait c'est pas bizarre si vous regardez
ça c'est juste une manière parmi
d'autres cas l'économie de réagir à un
monde dans lequel la croissance physique
est en train de disparaître dans un
monde il n'y a pas de croissance
on ne peut pas rembourser des dettes
avec des taux d'intérêts positif sauf en
faisant une pyramide de ponzi c'est à
dire en riant printemps pour rembourser
le principal plus ses intérêts et donc
en augmentant perpétuellement la dette
donc si on a de la dette perpétuelle ça
marche bien
si à un moment quelconque on est obligé
de rembourser la dette avec des revenus
réels par exemple les crédits
immobiliers parce que les particuliers
ont un peu de mal à créer de la monnaie
à ce moment vous allez avoir soin du
défaut soit des taux réels qui vont
devenir négatif où l'inflation est tout
tout tout sa partie du jeu et ce pétrole
qui mondialement d'augmenter + pourtant
il bénéficie d'un apport absolument
majeur des pétroles non conventionnels
ici vous avez l'évolution de la
production aux états unis vous voyez
qu'ils ont dépassé leur pic historique
de 70 grâce au challenge que vous voyez
là ce qui nécessite de fracturer la
roche et en ce qui concerne le canada
vous voyez que c'est grâce au sable
bitumineux que ça augmente alors
maintenant on va se tourner un peu vers
le bassin méditerranéen
vous avez ici à voisin qui appelle
l'algérie regardez la production de
pétrole de l'algérie
voyez elle augmente à l'augmenter
l'augmentent sa consommation de pétrole
augmente aussi tous les pays qui démarre
l'histoire de la production de pétrole
en étant producteur en général
subventionne leur carburant je serais
très étonné que ce pôle cas en algérie
j'ai pas été regardée mais à mon avis le
carburant vaut pas cher
en tout cas en egypte je suis choqué
c'est le cas et puis vous voyez depuis
la fin des années 2000 la production de
pétrole est en baisse
l'algérie a passé son pic de production
alors l'algérie a passé son pic de
production mais l'algérie est une
économie de rente dans laquelle vous
avez besoin des exportations de pétrole
pour payer les importations de
nourriture parce que la population n'est
pas autosuffisante en ce qui concerne la
nourriture au bon moment ils ont de quoi
mais la production de pétrole baisse la
population augmente viendra évidemment
un moment où ils auront plus de quoi
c'est absolument évident qu'est ce qui
se passe dans un pays dans lesquels les
gens ont plus de quoi gagner de quoi
manger
ideye de fou qu'est l'histoire nous l'a
montré un milliard de fois quand les
gens n'ont plus de quoi manger et de
vielles tout je vais vous montrer après
le printemps arabe qui est très
exactement les conséquences de ce truc
là ici vous avez l'egypte qui a été
aussi pendant longtemps un producteur de
pétrole significatif qui a passé son pic
qui a maintenant une bonne trentaine
d'années pardon mais par contre qui n'a
pas ralenti sa consommation de pétrole
pour autant alors l'egypte maintenant
ils sont devenus importateur de pétrole
mais dans un pays qui subventionne ces
carburants alors ça c'est monstrueux pas
ce que ça veut dire que quand il ya un
choc pétrolier
vous vous retrouvez avec une dépense
budgétaire absolument monstrueuse et par
ailleurs quand vous avez un choc
pétrolier c'est ce que je vous montrerai
après vous avez également une inflation
alimentaire une inflation pardon des
importations alimentaires parce qu'il se
trouve que sur les marchés financiers
mondiaux depuis 1974 s'il ya des belges
émigré dans la salle est bien le prix
des céréales et le prix des denrées
alimentaires sont totalement asservi ils
sont totalement indexée sur le prix du
pétrole
donc quand le prix du pétrole augmente
le prix de la nourriture augmente pour
tous les pays qui doivent importer leur
nourriture
donc là c'est double effet kiss cool
pour l'egypte si les prix du pétrole
augmentent leurs importations de pétrole
leur coûte un bras et la consommation
n'est pas tempéré dans le pays puisque
c'est subventionnés et leurs
importations de nourriture leur coûte un
bras également et vous allez voir que
très exactement ce qui s'est passé en
2000 ans si je regarde l'afrique dans
son ensemble puisque le cahier des
charges c'était de regarder un tout
petit peu plus au sud que les pays de la
rive sud
eh bien vous voyez que l'afrique pour le
moment elle a une production de pétrole
qui est supérieur à sa consommation mais
sa consommation augmente régulièrement
alors que sa production est passée par
un pic en 2009
et c'est un pic définitif art ça
reviendra pas à ce niveau là donc
l'afrique dans prise dans son ensemble
va aussi avoir un sujet l'assureur plane
au dessus on va maintenant passer au
climat alors le climat vous savez que
paris a accueilli en 2015 la coop 21
grâce à laquelle monsieur fabius s'est
transformée en commissaire priseur d'un
soir et a adjugé l'accord de paris qui
est censé nous sortir du caca climatique
pensons-nous généralement ce que vous
allez voir c'est que c'est pas aussi
simple que ça vous avez ici à graphique
qui vous représente depuis un siècle et
demi les émissions humaines de gaz à
effet de serre alors gaz à effet de
serre qu'est ce que c'est que ça gaz à
effet de serre c'est en physique quelque
chose de très simple c'est un gaz qui a
la propriété d'intercepter les
infrarouges terrestre vous savez que
votre corps émet des infrarouges d'aller
probablement déjà entendu parler c'est
infrarouge votre oeil n'est pas capable
de le voir donc si vous êtes dans la
nuit très sombre dans une pièce très
sombre et qu'il ya quelqu'un qui se
déplace et vous aussi et que vous
entendez pas ce qui se passe
vous pouvez lui rentrer dedans
voyez pas le corps avec vos yeux mais si
vous avez un oeil artificiel qui
s'appelle une caméra infrarouge va vous
arriver à voir le corps parce que le
notre corps rayonne cette longueur
d'onde particulière qui s'appelle les
infrarouges la surface de la terre qui
est à une température pas très éloignée
de celle de notre corps à la surface de
la terre et se balade un peu au dessus
de zéro degré alors très au-dessus l'été
où l'avait vu l'été dernier pas très au
dessus leader mais globalement on est un
peu on n'est pas très loin en
température de la surface de la terre
rayonne aussi de l'infrarouge tout
simplement parce qu'elle est chauffé par
le soleil et du coup ça lui permet
d'être à une température où elle rayonne
de la france à gaz à effet de serre
présents dans l'atmosphère depuis des
milliards d'années est tout simplement à
gaz qui absorbent ces infrarouge
terrestre
quand il est opaque aux infrarouges
terrisse ces gaz à effet de serre sont
connus depuis le milieu du 19e siècle
donc l'effet de serre est connu depuis
le début du 19e siècle c'est fourier
camisa au point fakara découvert ça et
les gaz à effet que les principaux gaz à
effet de serre que sont la vapeur d'eau
et le dioxyde de carbone sont connus
depuis le milieu du 19e siècle encore
donc tout ça relève de science qui est
très ancienne très bien et très
solidement étayées ici vous avez donc
les émissions humaines de gaz à effet de
serre c'est à dire les espèces chimiques
qui sont mises dans l'atmosphère et qui
vont augmenter l'opacité de l'atmosphère
aux infrarouges terroristes
le premier gaz à effet de serre que nous
mettons dans l'atmosphère et pour lequel
nous augmentons la quantité qui en a
c'est le co2 et là vous avez le co2 qui
provient de la combustion du charbon le
charbon s'est plaint de carbone puisque
c'est un de la vie ancienne c'est un
fossile de vie ancienne donc c'est plein
de carbone parce que les êtres vivants
sont plaints de carbone et quand vous
brûler du charbon vous oxydé du carbone
ça vous fait du co2 pareil avec le
pétrole le pétrole c'est un rêve de vie
ancienne
donc quand vous brûler du pétrole vous
oxydé du carbone et vous fait plein de
co2 pareil avec le gaz qui a beau être
naturel le pétrole est aussi naturel le
charbon au temps un je vous signal eh
bien vous oxydé du carbone puisque du
carbone dans le gaz naturel et vous
créez des émissions de co2 donc ici vous
avez les émissions de co2 qui
proviennent de l'énergie fossile non sur
ses trois premiers compartiments après
on a des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui viennent d'ailleurs
ici vous avez un petit machin violet là
c'est les cimenteries alors dans les
cimenteries
vous avez un processus qui n'est pas la
combustion qui aimait plein de co2
c'est le fait de couper des molécules de
calcaire sert de carbonate de calcium en
deux et quand vous coupez ses molécules
en deux l'un des morceaux c'est du co2
le carbonate de calcium caco3 très
exactement et qu'on vous l'a coupé en
deux cette molécule en la chauffant très
très fort c'est comme ça vous l'a coupé
en deux vous faites du co2 d'un côté et
de l'autre côté de la chaux vive
c'est haro et une fois vous avez
mélanger cette chauve y avait quelques
poudre de perlimpinpin ça vous donne le
ciment du reste il ya des gens dans
cette salle qui ont manipulé du ciment à
mains nues vous avez constaté que ça
vous bouffer la peau tout simplement
parce que le constituant principal du
silence et de la chaux c'est très
agressif au dessus vous avez un autre
compartiment des missions qui est la
déforestation
alors la déforestation sur terre c'est
essentiellement un processus d'abattis
brûlis pour dégager des nouvelles
surfaces agricoles et c'est
essentiellement piloté par la croissance
démographique et l'augmentation de la
part carnet dans la ration alimentaire
parce que ces deux processus demande
qu'on ait plus de surfaces agricoles et
ses surfaces agricoles peut pas les
prendre sur l'océan vous compliquez peut
pas les prendre sur les déserts c'est un
peu compliqué peut pas les prendre sur
la calotte antarctique c'est un peu
compliqué donc le seul endroit où on
peut prendre de nouvelles surfaces
agricoles c'est là où il ya des forêts
donc le déterminant premier de la
déforestation c'est je le redis la
croissance démographique et
l'augmentation de la part carnet dans
l'alimentation des hommes et donc on
coupe les forêts pour mettre des champs
à la place après vous avez ici un
compartiment des missions qui n'est plus
du co2 donc jusqu'à maintenant c'était
que du co2 tout ça c'est du pardon tout
ça c'est du co2 en jaune c'est plus du
co2 et du méthane
alors le medan c'est le gaz la
putréfaction vous savez c'est celui que
les collégiens en flânant mettant un
briquet derrière leurs flatulences ce
qui est fait beaucoup rire
donc c'est le gaz de la putréfaction
c'est celui qui arrive quand vous fait
fermenter de la matière organique à
l'abri de l'oxygène de l'air
alors à part chez les collégiens ou est
ce que ça se produise ce genre de choses
ça se produit dans les marécages de
façon naturelle
ça se produit dans des marécages
artificielle qui s'appelle les rizières
ça se produit dans l'estomac des
ruminants donc les ruminants
roth du méthane c'est très important les
monogastriques le pet
mais les ruminants le rot ça ne passe
pas à l'intestin donc dans les estomacs
des vaches vous avez de la fermentation
de l'herbe qu'elle mange
et cette fermentation produit du méthane
qui ressort par le haut et enfin au
dessus vous avez d'autres gaz à effet de
serre les gaz qui sont utilisés comme
fluide réfrigérant et puis le protoxyde
d'azoté qui est un sous produit de
l'épandage des engrais essentiellement
alors à nouveau
vous voyez que ces émissions pour le
moment croissent et embellissent depuis
un siècle et demi et il ya deux
processus dont on parle aujourd'hui
comme étant des choses qui vont dans le
bon sens qui ont démarré il ya une
vingtaine d'années qui sont une part
l'augmentation des renouvelables et
d'autre part la dématérialisation de
l'économie en fait vous les voyez pas
non plus sur cette courbe corps donc ça
existe dans les discours pour le moment
ça n'existe pas dans la réalité
alors je vais vous dire un truc à cette
occasion que j'adore dire donc
heureusement que j'ai pas les
journalistes de var matin au téléphone
il n'y a pas le moindre lien entre la
pagination dans le journal et
l'importance réelle des choses dans le
monde
je vous le répète une deuxième fois ou
non c'est bon
il n'y a pas le moindre lien c'est par
ailleurs un petit lien il n'y a pas le
moindre lien donc ne croyez pas qu'un
sujet dans le journal parle souvent est
un sujet structurant pour l'évolution de
ce qui se passe dans le monde
j'en reviens à la sextape de monsieur
benjamin griveaux journal on a beaucoup
parlé je ne crois pas que ça va
fondamentalement changé la manière dont
le monde va se comporter
donc vous avez insiste vraiment
là-dessus et il ya des tas de trucs qui
sont essentiels pour la structuration du
monde vous ai parlé tout à l'heure du
pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel dans le monde en 2008 qui
a vu un papier dans le journal là dessus
bon donc on lit le même journal et il
parle pas des trucs importants d'accord
j'insiste vraiment c'est très important
d'avoir ça en tête donc pour le moment
ça n'existe que dans le journal que
l'économie se soient dématérialisés et
l'ajout de capacités urinaires et permis
de diminuer les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre ça n'existe que dans le journal
regardez pas comme ça ça n'existe pas
dans la vraie vie une bonne partie donc
de ses émissions viennent de l'énergie
mais j'en ai déjà parlé donc j'en
reparle pas le dioxyde de carbone alors
c'est là qu'on va commencer à
s'intéresser à la stratégie de long
terme de nos habits militaires
le dioxyde de carbone est comme chacun
sait un oxyde puisque le dictionnaire
est bien fait et si c'est un dioxyde il
est deux fois oxydes du reste donc au
kit les oxydes ont la particularité sur
terre d'être des espèces chimiques
éternelle dit autrement un oxyde si vous
ne lui donnez pas de l'énergie pour
qu'ils se réduisent pour qu'il se
débarrasse de son oxygène
il est éternel par exemple depuis qu'il
ya de l'oxygène dans l'atmosphère
terrestre
il rêvait pas au début il a fallu
attendre l'apparition de la vie pour
qu'elle l'oxygène dans l'atmosphère
terrestre mais depuis qu'il ya de
l'oxygène dans l'atmosphère terrestre
l'oxygène atmosphérique à oxyder tout le
fer qui se trouvait sur terre et
aujourd'hui quand vous trouvez dû faire
c'est de l'oxydé de fer et cet oxyde de
fer il est là sous forme d'oxydé de fer
depuis des centaines de millions
d'années
des centaines de millions d'années c'est
parfaitement stable d'accord
eh bien le dioxyde de carbone c'est
exactement pareil une fois qu'on l'a mis
dans l'atmosphère il n'a pas de
processus chimiques d'épuration de
l'atmosphère donc une temps qu'il est
dans l'atmosphère notre co2 il est
éternel
tant qu'il est dans l'atmosphère il est
éternel pour qu'il sorte de l'atmosphère
il faut qu'il se retrouve au contact de
la surface planétaire où là il ya deux
processus qui peuvent le retirer
le premier processus est un processus de
dissolution de l'océan
c'est un équilibrage de pression
partielle ses terres que s'il ya plus de
co2 dans l'atmosphère que dans l'océan
le co2 atmosphérique dû au co2 océanique
pousse toi un peu de la fée mois de la
place et traque
il ya une partie du co2 atmosphérique
qui rentrent dans l'océan pas par par
effet de pression j'ai envie de dire
évidemment c'est un processus qui
s'arrête quand les deux compartiments
sont équilibrés et pire si un jour vous
retirer du co2 d'atmosphère à ce moment
il ya une partie du co2 océanique qui se
dit ah bah tiens ya plus de place là au
dessus et craque et ressort mais c'est
tout ça est un processus de contact ça
se passe au contact de l'océan le et
c'est pas un processus chimique et au
passage ce co2 qui rentre dans l'océan
acidifie l'océan vous en parlerai après
le deuxième processus de contact c'est
la photosynthèse
c'est la reprise du co2 par l'action des
plantes avec un apport énergétique qui
est la lumière du soleil
vous avez besoin d'un photon c'est à
dire d'un grain de lumière d'un grain
d'énergie a mené par le soleil et à ce
moment-là plantes pour le co2 d'un côté
le grain d'énergie de l'autre avec le
grain d'énergie tel un petit marteau
elle casse le co2 elle nous rend
l'oxygène montre plutôt sympa et elle se
garde carbone qu'elle va utiliser avec
de l'eau pour faire des sucres et des
molécules plus élaboré
d'hydrates de carbone donc voilà ce qui
se passe et ça c'est au contact des
plantes
donc vous n'avez que deux processus et
c'est les processus de contact la
conséquence du fait que le co2 est
chimiquement éternel temps qu'il est
dans l'atmosphère c'est que après arrêt
des émissions j'insiste après arrêt des
émissions 40% du surplus de co2 que nous
aurons créé sera toujours au dessus de
nos têtes au bout d'un siècle 20% de ce
surplus sera toujours au dessus de nos
têtes au bout de bilan enfin pas au
dessus de nous on sera mort depuis
longtemps et 10% de ce surplus sera
encore au dessus des têtes deux qui
vivra à ce moment là dans dix villes ans
à cause de cette caractéristique
intrinsèque chimique du co2 il faut
comprendre qu' il n'existe pas de bouton
reset
en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique à aucun moment vous pouvez
dire bon là ça va je commence à trouver
l'expérience un peu désagréable j'appuie
sur le bouton stop et tout s'arrête
c'est impossible ça n'existe pas
d'accord en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique
nous avons affaire à un processus que
nous avons mis en route qui sera
irréversible à l'échelle des temps
historiques bien vers cible koor à un
moment on peut pas dire [ __ ] si
j'avais su comme disait petit gibus là
j'aurais pas venu non pas ce processus
va donc s'échelonner sur des pattes tant
qu'ils sont considérablement plus long
que celui d'une ou plusieurs vies
humaines et surtout considérablement
plus long que l'est pas tant que nous
avons maintenant l'habitude de
considérer avec les systèmes de gestion
que nous avons mis en place
qu'il s'agisse des élections ou du
budget de l'armée qui revient tous les
ans donc les pattes tant que nous avons
mis en place pour la gestion de nos
problèmes sont totalement inadaptés à ce
problème totalement inadapté à ce
problème
ce qui est pas une bonne nouvelle parce
que ça veut dire que si on fait pas un
gros effort sur nous mêmes pour accepter
des sacrifices de manière volontaire au
moment où la régulation involontaire du
problème aura lieu parce qu'elle aura
lieu de toute façon sur une planète
finie il n'est pas complètement exclu
que ça balaye la démocratie au passage
là aussi les militaires dans cette salle
sont bien placés pour le savoir
la démocratie n'est ni un truc éternel
ni un truc répandu partout donc c'est
pas du tout exclu que ce soit tout à
fait transitoire aussi qu on ait le
droit d'aller voter aux municipales ou
aux présidentielles à cause de cette
très très longue durée de résidence du
co2 dans l'atmosphère est bien ma foi
vous avez ici la traduction de nos
émissions croissantes c'est que la
concentration est également croissante
donc la concentration c'est la quantité
de co2 que vous avez dans l'atmosphère
ici c'est graduée en millionième 1
millionième c1 milite par mètre cube un
accord donc là vous avez la quantité de
co2 dans l'atmosphère depuis 1962 hasard
c'est pas parce que je suis narcissique
qui se trouve que c'est à une naissance
mais quand j'ai trouvé cette série c'est
inquiète des marais dont vous avez des
millilitres par mètre cube
depuis cette époque là et vous voyez que
ça a gagné 100 millilitres par mètre
cube
depuis que je suis née alors vous pouvez
aussi mettre sur cette courbe
l'apparition de l'haïti la
dématérialisation et c'est moi je peux
vous mettre autre chose pour être les
négociations climat donc ici vous avez
la coop un qui est un grand succès
puisqu'on vient de ratifier la
convention climat ici vous avez kyoto
qui est un grand succès puisque on
appris des objectifs de réduction ici
vous avez copenhague qui est un gros
échec puisqu'il parait-il que c'était un
gros échec
et là vous avez pareil est un grand
succès je reviens à ce que je vous
disais sur les médias le fait qu une
coop sont un succès ou un échec langage
que le journaliste qui a écrit l'article
et personne d'autre pour le moment c'est
surtout des choses qui n'ont aucun effet
ça n'a aucun effet et pourquoi cela n'a
aucun effet là aussi les militaires le
savent bien
parce que le processus tout ce qui
procède de l'assemblée générale des
nations-unies procède d'un système dans
lequel les gens doivent se mettre
d'accord à l'unanimité sur ce qu'ils
vont faire un système unanimiste est un
système qui ne débouchent sur aucune
contrainte puisque n'importe qui qui est
un effort à faire qui considère comme
inacceptable mais son veto donc un
système qui décident à l'unanimité est
un système qui ne peut déboucher que sur
des accords qui ne compterait une
personne et c'est très exactement ce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui l'accord de paris
quand vous regarder dans le détail est
un accord qui ne contraint personne
c'est faux de dire que l'accord de paris
nous garantit les deux degrés tout ce
que nous garantie d'accor de paris
c'est que les gens vont dire qu'il
s'engage à faire quelque chose mais vous
pouvez vous très bien vous engager à
augmenter vos émissions ça vaut dans
l'accord de paris aucun problème donc on
dit qu'on va faire ce qu'il faut pour
arriver à 2 degrés mais on dit pas
comment donc c'est une promesse
d'ivrogne pour le moment voilà demain
j'arrête de boire ici vous avez la
traduction de ces émissions croissantes
et de cette concentration croissante sur
le marqueur qu'on utilise le plus
fréquemment quand on parle de dérive
climatique qui est la température mais
après je vous vous en évoquer d'autres
l'attend la température ici elle est
calée à 0 à ce qu'on appelle l'ère
préindustrielle c'est à dire qu'avant
qu'on se mette à faire joujou avec les
machines à vapeur et les moteurs à
combustion interne et à ce moment là
donc le 7-0 de référence sur la courbe
évidemment la température de la planète
étaient pas et heureusement
et puis vous voyez que globalement ça
reste stable pendant un siècle
et puis à au bout d'un siècle ça
commence à augmenter doucettement puis
ça augmente de plus en plus rapidement
et nous sommes ici à l'avenir évidemment
ce qu'on va émettre n'est pas écrit on
peut y mettre un peu plus un peu moins
on peut arrêter d'émettre pas ce qui a
pu passer de pétrole avoir plein de
charbon et mettre tout ce qu'on veut et
cetera de plus pouvoir émettre pascal
coronavirus est donc ici vous avez la
réponse en température du système
planétaire en fonction des scénarios
d'émissions qui ont été rentrés dans la
basse qui représente le système
climatique
quelque chose qu'il est essentiel de
noter sur ce graphique c'est que vous
voyez que quel que soit le scénario des
missions y compris celui là qui doit
être un quasi arrêt quasi total des
émissions est bien ce qui se passe sur
les 20 années qui viennent et toujours
la même chose à cause de la longévité du
co2 dans l'atmosphère
le climat des 20 prochaines années est
déjà totalement embarqué dans nos
émissions passées ce que nous allons
émettre à l'avenir n'a aucune espèce
d'importance pour ce qui va se passer
dans les batailles et qu'il vienne et
dans les 20 années qui viennent la
dérive climatique va concevoir continuer
donc je vais vous le dire d'une autre
manière
l'été 2010 9 c'est déjà du passé
ça sera pire plus tard
quoi qu'on fasse
le climat de l'année 2020 il est perdu
de toute façon quoi qu'on fasse quoi
qu'on fasse
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
sur la formidable inertie du système
donc on est dans une machine ou la
[ __ ] de frein quand on appuie dessus
la seule chose qui se passe c'est que
l'auto continue d'accélérer pendant 20
ans avant éventuellement de commençait à
décélérer
je vais vous le dire encore autrement à
quelques moments qu'on décide de
s'agiter sur la baisse des émissions on
travaille pour ses enfants
on travaille pour vingt ans après il
vous voyez que l'élévation de
température dont on parle et qui est le
marqueur du surplus d'énergie embarquée
par le système
en fait c'est que ça qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que le système embarque
un surplus d'énergie qui aujourd'hui
vaut cent fois l'énergie utilisée par
les hommes
dit autrement l'effet de serre
supplémentaires qu'on a mis en route en
voit dans le système climatique chaque
année 100 fois plus d'énergie que la
chaleur dégagée par la totalité de
l'énergie utilisée par les hommes
cent fois plus eh bien ça va réchauffer
la température des équilibres de la
planète
alors est-ce que c'est grave docteur bah
je ne sais pas on va voir ici vous avez
une carte des écosystèmes qui prennent
place en europe aujourd'hui
à partir du moment où on ne leur fait
pas des misères pour les remplacer par
des cultures ou des trucs totalement
futile comme des bases navales ou des
grandes écoles
donc si on les remplace par les trucs
importants manger sur place pas pardon
par les ricains portant des champs et
bien voilà à quoi ressemble les
écosystèmes que nous avons aujourd'hui
enfin que nous avions plus exactement au
xxème siècle en europe qui sont
essentiellement des forêts ça veut dire
qu'il pleut suffisamment et que le
climat n'est ni trop chaud ni trop froid
pour que des gros espèces végétales se
porte bien et je dis bien que nous
avions puisque maintenant ça fait 2
était que les gros espèces végétales
commencent à se porter un peu moins bien
pour ceux d'entre vous dans la salle qui
suivent un peu l'actualité forestière
vous avez dû voir que en ce moment ça
rigolait pas trop et malheureusement à
l'avenir ça rigolera de moins en moins
voilà l'europe ya 20 me dans l'europe ya
vingt mille ans est au coeur de la
dernière ère glaciaire au quaternaire
serre sur les 3 derniers millions
d'années
le climat a naturellement variés part
sur le climat varie sur terre
depuis qu'il existe une atmosphère le
climat varie sur terre sous l'effet des
facteurs géologiques qui sont changeants
dans les facteurs géologiques qui sont
changeants vous en avait un qui est
changeant au cours du quaternaire qui
est les paramètres astronomiques de la
terre sur la terre est plus ou moins
inclinés sur le plan de l'orbité et c
est cette modification des paramètres
astronomiques vient du fait que la terre
et le soleil ça n'est pas un paisible
mariage à deux c'est un tumultueux
mariage à 10 avec la terre qui est
notamment très attiré par jupiter et
saturne
j'ai un petit faible pour jupiter et
saturne et donc la traction de jupiter
et saturne sur la terre modifie les
paramètres astronomiques de la terre
avec une quasi périodicité de cent mille
ans et c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous avez eu au moment du quaternaire
des ères glaciaires et des heures
chaudes qui se sont succédé avec une
périodicité d'environ cent mille ans
alors hier à milan
on est donc au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire c'est là qu'il fait le plus
froid dans cette oscillation que nous
avons eues au quaternaire alors la
première chose que vous voyez à
l'évidence sur l'europe de l'époque
c'est que je ne sais pas si aujourd'hui
nous avons des programmes de coopération
militaire avec les suédois et à l'époque
le cri pen n'était pas un problème la
concurrence de sable n'était pas un
problème et il fabrique des sous marins
si je crois les suédois ces cochons donc
c'était pas des concurrents on se
fichait les suédois est du reste on se
fiche également des allemands puisque
vous voyez que l'essentiel des allemands
sont sous la glace la scandinavie et le
nord de l'europe sont recouverts d'une
énorme calotte glaciaire qui fait trois
kilomètres d'épaisseur
voilà qui a aussi une autre calotte a le
bon goût de nous priver des écossais au
tournoi des six nations
blake se soit pas les pires et vous
voyez que les lyonnais peuvent faire du
ski sans quitter lyon puisque les
glaciers des alpes descendent pardon
jusqu'à lyon pour le canada est
également sous la glace à cette époque
là le canada est recouvert de trois
kilomètres de glace tout même pareil que
la scandinavie pour faire c'est très
très gros glaçons c'est comme dans votre
congélateur il faut prendre de l'eau le
glaçon n'apparaît pas spontanément dans
le congélateur faut mettre de l'eau dans
bac à glaçons alors là l'eau qui a été
mise dans le bac à très très gros
glaçons elle ne peut venir que d'un seul
endroit c'est l'océan il n'y a pas
d'autres réserves d'eau sur terre
donc la nature a fait un énorme
transfert d'eau de l'océan vers les
calottes glaciaires et comme le fond de
l'océan le fond de la baignoire est
toujours au même endroit et bien le
niveau de la baignoire a baissé et il a
pas baissé qu'un peu il a baissé de 120
mètres donc à l'époque pascal au sort a
été au chômage
y'a pas de manche et donc pas de préfet
maritime pour la manche voilà votre dos
elle peut partir en vacances en
permanence et il n'y a pas de problème
de croisement des navires ont roulé dans
la côte et d'ouest en est à tout ça
n'existe pas il ya quelques fiscaliste
sont également au chômage voyez que
comme y'a pas la manche n'y a pas les
aigles en augmentant anglo-normandes n'y
a pas de paradis fiscaux et enfin les
juristes qui s'occupe du break sites
sont aussi au chômage puisque vous avez
la continuité territoriale entre la
france et la grande bretagne n'ont qu'à
pas de bauxite donc la géographie
européenne a un tout petit peu changé à
cette époque là le climat étant beaucoup
plus froid il y a moins d'évaporation et
il est beaucoup plus accus et dans ce
climat beaucoup plus froid et beaucoup
plus sec
vous avez en europe d'esthète qui
ressemble à ce que vous avez aujourd'hui
au nord de la sibérie et donc à cette
époque là la totalité de la population
française c'est les effectifs de l'armée
d'aujourd'hui à peu de choses près cent
mille personnes
c'est ça que vous avez aujourd'hui sur
la totalité du territoire donc loin de
conscrits du cou à cette époque c'est ça
que vous avez sur la totalité du
territoire à cette époque là parce que
c'est tout ce que les écosystèmes
maigrichon de l'époque fait de b à
ramasser et de babouches quand ils
veulent bien se laisser gribouillé est
capable de fournir comme nourriture à
des animaux en bout de chaîne
alimentaire comme donc d'accord sans lui
personne à l'évidence quand l'europe est
passée de l'état de gauche à l'état de
droit tel s'est réchauffée est d'accord
que c'est rare que les glaçons fonde
quand on est refroidie ça c'est inscrit
dans le cadre d'un réchauffement
planétaire dire qu'à cette époque là la
terre dans son ensemble s'est réchauffée
aussi et bien le réchauffement
planétaire qui a permis à l'europe de
passer de l'état de gauche à l'état de
droite c'est 0,05 degré par siècle
09 05 degrés par siècle sur dix mille
ans au total 5 degrés donc là vous avez
le résultat d'une expérience
leur mère nature met gracieusement à
notre disposition pour pas un rond comme
tout ce que mère nature met à
disposition où on peut constater ce que
donne un réchauffement climatique de
quelques degrés 5° en l'occurrence 4 5
degrés en l'espace de dix mille ans
alors maintenant très bonne nouvelle
pour les militaires dans cette salle
quelques degrés de réchauffement en un
siècle ça sera la guerre partout donc
vous allez avoir du boulot ça va être
une déstabilisation des conditions
installés qui va aller à une vitesse
telle que les sociétés sédentaires au
surplus en stress énergétique sur une
partie du siècle seront totalement
incapable de gérer dans la joie et la
bonne humeur
alors je vais un peu détaillé maintenant
mais c'est absolument évident que ça va
être un facteur de déstabilisation
absolument massif des sociétés
installées alors je commence avec
quelques conséquences
ici vous avez avec un réchauffement de 4
degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle le nombre de jours par
an où les conditions extérieures ne
seront pas tenable pour un individu pas
tenable ça veut dire qu'il fait trop
chaud et trop humide pour que vous
puissiez transpiré pour vous refroidir
et donc vous mourrez d'hyperthermie donc
vous voyez que toute la bande
équatoriale
c'est là qu'il fait chaud et humide il
ya un risque que alors évidemment les
gens qui sont là ils vont pas être
contents d'être là qui vont avoir envie
d'aller ailleurs
et en général quand les mouvements de
foule arrive c'est jamais des migrations
qui font le tour de la terre c'est pas
200 millions d'indonésiens qui vont tout
d'un coup aller s'installer aux
etats-unis non ils vont commencer par
aller essayer d'aller chez les voisins
qui eux mêmes seront pas très bien ici
vous avez l'évolution des précipitations
dans un monde qui s'est réchauffée de 2
degrés alors le une des choses qu'il
faut savoir c'est que aujourd'hui vous
avez une grande circulation
atmosphérique qui part de l'équateur et
qui va jusque vers les tropiques qu'on
appelle les cellules de hadley qui
grosso modo se décrit de la manière
suivante à l'équateur vous avez une très
forte avance avec une très forte
évaporation qui renforce encore cette
ascendance et après un air qui passe en
altitude jusqu'au dessus des tropiques
où là il redescend c'est ce qu'on
appelle la zone de subsidence en étant
très sec et ça vous explique pourquoi à
l'équateur il n'arrête pas de flotter et
ça vous explique pourquoi aux tropiques
vous avez une zone sèche donc
typiquement les zones de désert sont aux
alentours des tropiques dans un climat
qui se réchauffe 7 sur cette zone de
subsidence va avoir tendance à se
décaler un peu vers les pôles se décaler
vers l'épaule ça veut dire typiquement
que les zones tropicales
la marge des zones tropicales qui est
située vers l'épaule va avoir tendance à
hériter d'un climat un peu plus tropical
et ça ça va notamment déclenché un
assèchement des zones de la marge des
zones tropicales qui se situe un peu
plus vers les pôles le bassin
méditerranéen
vous le voyez dans cette simulation est
aux avant-postes des zones qui
s'assèchent
si la zone s'assèche et que par ailleurs
la température s'élève et que
l'évaporation augmente
l'humidité des sols baisse de manière
significative et à partir du moment où
significative les rendements agricoles
décroissent il est envisagé dans le
cadre d'un climat qui se réchauffe que
d'une manière générale les rendements
agricoles décroissent alors vous avez
aujourd'hui déjà les rendements des
écosystèmes qui décroissent très bonne
nouvelle
depuis l'an 2000 la photosynthèse des
forêts est en train de décroître
c'est à dire qu'avant alors que les
puits naturels reprenait une fraction
croissante de nos émissions
là maintenant ils sont déjà passés dans
un état où ils prennent une fraction des
croissante de nos émissions
parce que vous avez déjà un stress sur
les écosystèmes installés qui va au delà
de leur capacité d'adaptation et nous
avons pris qu'un domaine n'avons pris
qu'un degré et la moitié de la
superficie française a cramé en
australie ces derniers mois 20 millions
d'hectares
donc vous allez avoir un stress sur les
écosystèmes installez vous allez avoir
un stress aussi sur les rendements
agricoles et ça dans un monde dans
lequel on nous dit qu'il va y avoir plus
de monde etc
c'est dans un mois c'est un monde dans
lequel vous voyez la quantité de terres
arables par personne dès crois tout
simplement parce qu'on est plus en plus
nombreux et qu'ils poussent pas des
continents à mesure qu'on est plus
nombreux alors aujourd'hui on s'en sort
bien grâce à l'énergie
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui a permis aux
rendements céréaliers dans la beauce
d'être multipliée par 6 à 7 entre 1945
et 1975
les engrais azotés fabriqués à partir du
gaz
les tracteurs qui fonctionne au pétrole
les phytosanitaires qui sont fabriqués à
partir du pétrole donc la raison pour
laquelle le hamburger chez mcdo en
parlons pas de chez quick aussi vos
trois fois rien aujourd'hui
ça s'appelle le pétrole et le gaz
nonobstant le fait que par ailleurs les
surfaces agricoles sont en diminution
dans le monde
rapporté à l'individu mais à partir du
moment où vous aurez plus le pétrole et
le gaz aussi disponible qu'est ce qui va
se passer sur les rendements agricoles
arrive on se met à baisser et ça c'est
un deuxième facteur de pression
alors ça c'est pas dans les simulations
du giec pour une raison très simple
c'est que les climatologues sont myopes
sur l'approvisionnement énergétique donc
eux ils vous font des simulations à aide
entre guillemets constante
en ce qui concerne l'agriculture eux ils
voient pas que il pourrait y avoir moins
de pétrole à mettre dans les tracteurs
et surtout moins d'engrais à épandre sur
les champs mais voilà est en france
depuis 20 ans maintenant à peu près les
rendements à l'hectare plafonne ils vont
arrêter d'augmenter
nonobstant le fait que l'on met de plus
en plus d'engrais et qu'on mette etc
alors maintenant voici quelques pays sur
le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
donc ici vous avez la même chose pour
l'algérie vous voyez ça a tendance à
baisser l'algérie importe par ailleurs
sa nourriture pour le moment à l'export
du pétrole et à la porte sa nourriture
ici vous avez la même chose pour la
tunisie
ici vous avez la même chose pour
l'egypte partout ça baisse ici vous avez
la manière dont va évoluer la
pluviométrie sur le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen depuis un siècle et vous
voyez très clairement apparaître un
déficit de pluviométrie dans les années
récentes
et ce déficit de pluviométrie est
peut-être une des raisons qui font que
vous avez eu un décrochage en syrie
entre la production agricole et la
population vous avez ici un graphique
qui vous retrace sur quelques décennies
l'évolution de la population que vous
avez avec ce trait bleu l'évolution de
la production agricole que vous avez
avec cette courbe verte et vous voyez
très nettement que au milieu des années
2000 les deux commence à décrocher alors
la syrie la plus de pétrole a exporté à
ce moment là elle a passé son pic de
production il ya longtemps qu'ils ont
plus l a jamais eu beaucoup de pétrole
elle est mal connecté au marché mondial
et à ce moment vous commencez à avoir un
stress alimentaire qui peut
difficilement être compensée par des
exportations et c'est exactement le même
phénomène qui s'est passé en tunisie et
en egypte la tunisie comme l'egypte sont
des gros importateurs de denrées
alimentaires l'egypte à l'époque était
le premier importateur de blé au monde
l'egypte un portait à l'époque un quart
des céréales qu'elle utilisait et
probablement des proportions supérieures
dans d'autres produits lui la viande etc
est ce que vous voyez c'est qu'au moment
des chocs pétroliers
l'augmentation des vingt partants au
moment des chocs pétroliers de 2005 2008
oui l'augmentation dans la foulée des
prix du pétrole du prix des céréales
1 alors que dans le même temps à cause
de ce fichu pétrole l'économie
occidentale est par terre et les
touristes restent chez eux donc moins de
recettes à l'exportation pour ces pays
très dépendant du tourisme plus de coûts
d'importation
le prix de la nourriture devient
intolérable pour les populations et vous
avez des votes de la fin donc ce qui
s'est passé en tunisie et en egypte en
2011 et peut-être ce qui s'est passé en
syrie exactement au même moment soit dit
en passant c'est des émeutes de la faim
le maroc qui est qui a une production
agricole plus importante ne bascule pas
et l'algérie qui se trouve voir ses
exportations d'hydrocarbures prendre de
la valeur pile au moment où les
importations de nourriture se mettent à
valoir plus cher ne bascule pas non plus
alors il ya d'autres facteurs
conjoncturels etc mais c'est quand même
troublant de noter que ya une
correspondance parfaite entre les pays
qui se trouvent
en tenaille entre l'inflation
alimentaire et un défaut des
exportations dû à la crise énergétique
et les pays où chaque coup ça a clashé
si on regarde vers l'avenir
le giec vous dit qu'à partir de 2,5 à 3
degrés l'élévation de température vous
aurez de l'insécurité alimentaire
généralisée dans le monde donc de
l'insécurité alimentaire généralisée
dans le monde
ça veut dire le bordel partout qu'il
suffit de relire ses cours d'histoire
très très clair alors bougez pas il ya
durable ici vous avez la manière enfin
la propension qu'ont les forêts a brûlé
à la fin du xxème siècle et là vous avez
la même chose en 2040 envoyé en 2040
l'aquitaine est à risque comme la
méditerranée aujourd'hui et la forêt de
fontainebleau et à risque comme
l'aquitaine aujourd'hui est évidemment
la forêt méditerranéenne sera à risque
comme l'australie d'aujourd'hui les
phénomènes extrêmes vont s'intensifier
alors ça c'est quelque chose qu'il est
assez facile d'expliquer avec les mains
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que les
gaz à effet de serre étaient des gaz qui
interceptait le rayonnement infrarouge
terrestre près du sol
de ce fait quand vous augmenter la
quantité de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère
ça va confiné l'énergie près du sol mais
corrélativement ça fait moins
d'infrarouge qui sont disponibles pour
réchauffer la haute partie de
l'atmosphère puisqu'ils ont été
absorbées près du sol et donc la
différence de température entre la basse
couche de l'atmosphère par la base
partie de l'atmosphère et la partie plus
élevé augmente
une des marques indubitable du
réchauffement climatique par supplément
d'effet de serre c'est que la
stratosphère se refroidit alors que si
c'était le soleil qui augmentait sa
puissance on devrait observer linverse
parce que si le soleil augmente
l'énergie qu'ils nous envoient il
augmente notamment la quantité d'ultra
violets qui nous envoie ses ultras
violets sont interceptés dans la
stratosphère par l'ozone et donc s'il ya
plus du cra violet a intercepté la
température de la stratosphère s'élève
donc un réchauffement qui arrivent par
le soleil vous avez la stratosphère qui
se réchauffe
un réchauffement qui arrivent par
supplément d'effet de serre vous avez la
stratosphère qui se refroidit or les
ballons sont nous disent depuis 40 ans
que la stratosphère se refroidit donc ça
c'est une des marques qui permet de dire
il n'y a pas le moindre doute sur le
fait que ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment il ya des hommes il
ya juste pas de débat d'accord c'est
peut-être le soleil donc quand la
température de la stratosphère se
refroidit et que la température de la
basse couche de l'atmosphère augmente ça
veut dire que la différence de
température entre le sol et la
stratosphère augmente et cette
différence de température c'est celle là
qui vais en route les pompes convective
qui alimente les phénomènes extrêmes
c'est ça qui met en route les ouragans
c'est ça qui met en route les tornades
et des orages
la raison pour laquelle vous avez des
orages d'été c'est parce que l'été la
température la stratosphère est à peu
près la même par contre la température
au sol est considérablement plus élevés
donc la différence de température entre
les deux plus importantes et votre pompe
convective elle est plus puissante des
orages d'hiver sont assez rare quand
sans avoir maintenant mais sont ramassés
donc à cause de ceux de ce que je viens
de vous expliquer avec les mains les
phénomènes extrêmes vont s'intensifier
dans le monde et du reste ce que vous
disent les modèles c'est exactement ça
c'est que l'intensité des la fréquence
on sait pas et c'est par contre les
intensités les vents maximaux etc vont
augmenter et pour ceux d'entre vous qui
s'intéresse aux ouragans vous avec les
ouragans de catégorie 5
c'est à dire les plus violents ont une
fréquence qui a tendance à augmenter au
cours du temps revenons à la mer ou à ce
qu'il a fait monter le les calottes
polaires vont contribuer plus ou moins à
l'élévation du niveau de l'océan et
malheureusement peut-être plus le
groenland a commencé à fondre
il ya tout un tas de processus
d'amplification qui font qu'à partir de
maintenant ça ne s'arrêtera plus et ça
va contribuer pour 3,6 m aux halles à 1
la hausse du niveau de l'eau dans les
siècles à venir
je ne sais pas pour quel niveau de l'eau
est ce que la rade de toulon est prévu
qu'elle hausse du niveau de l'eau donc
là le groenland à quelques siècles à on
a le temps de faire quelques travaux
vont mieux les faire avant qu'après
parce que vous avez compris dans
quelques
dizaine d'années ou siècle et le rapid
tractopelle l'antarctique de l'ouest
pourraient être victimes d'une
déstabilisation alors c'est un phénomène
qui est très différent l'antarctique de
l'ouest est un vaste château de cartes
de glaciers qui sont arc boutés les uns
sur les autres
hier château de cartes s'est des cartes
qui sont arc boutés les uns sur les
autres
d'accord tout est en équilibre vous
enlevez une carte ça se casse la gueule
et bien un château de cartes de glaciers
c'est exactement pareil
ils sont tous en équilibre les uns
contre les autres et l'ensemble est la
base du château de cartes
ici pardon l'ensemble est posée sur un
socle rocheux qui est sous marins et en
déclivité sous marin en déclivité et la
base du château de cartes c'est ce qu'on
appelle les glaciers émissaire c'est à
dire les glaciers dont les langues
terminal flotte sur l'eau et stabilisent
l'ensemble si vous avez la mer qui
devient plus chaude elle va vous
grignotez ce qu'elle est en train de
faire les langues terminal par le bas
après quoi vous avez l'eau de mer qui
peut s'infiltrer entre la langue
terminale est le socle rocheux sous
marins et puis une fois que ça a
commencé
glou glou glou glou glou ça grignote et
à ce moment vous avez les glaciers
émissaire qui se mettent à filer
beaucoup plus vite vers la mer et
l'ensemble est en risque de
déstabilisation
et si cette calotte antarctique de
l'ouest dont les recherches les plus
récentes montrent que au dernier
interglaciaire avec une température plus
élevée de 1.5 à 2 degrés par rapport à
l'ère préindustrielle elle avait
probablement disparu donc si cette
calotte se désagrège et se transforme en
icebergs sait plus si m pour l'océan
mondial
là aussi avec un pas de temps qui est de
l'ordre du siècle mais les scientifiques
vous disait il ya quelques années ces
quelques siècles maintenant et vous
dites on sait pas alors c'est pas une
semaine mais on sait pas et quand vous
regardez les indicateurs avancés sur
l'évolution de cette calotte globalement
ça sent pas bon
alors ici si m potentiellement 3 6
mètres plus la dilatation du niveau de
l'eau va plus la dilatation de l'eau je
veux dire
si on va plus vite que les deux degrés
en 2100 voilà à quoi pourrait ressembler
l'europe du nord d'ici quelques siècles
donc les flamands les wallons ils ont
intérêt à bien s'entendre et nous avons
intérêt à inventer des bateaux qui n'ont
pas besoin de port d'attache puisque
nous aurons ouvert la route des glaces
et à côté du groenland pour ne plus
pouvoir partir d'eau qu'un port et plus
boire arrivée dans aucun sport
ils sont tous ou alors c'est dans
longtemps met le doigt sur la gâchette
est aujourd'hui un c'est dans longtemps
met le doigt sur la gâchette s'est tout
de suite parce que ça ça arrive si on
franchit pardon les 2 degrés de hausse
en 2100 et on va les franchir le co2 est
un repris par l'océan il acidifie
l'océan l'acidification de l'océan
handicap la synthèse du calcaire dont
ont besoin tout un tas de bestioles qui
vivent dans l'océan pour le moment pas
les homards ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle mais quand même tout un tas
d'autres bestioles dont une bonne partie
du peloton
le réchauffement climatique ça c'est
connu depuis plus d'un siècle grâce aux
travaux d'art enius s'applique alors
vous avez compris qu'ils refroidissent
est la stratosphère c'est une de ses
parts acté ristic il en a une autre
c'est qui les plus rapides au pôle aux
tropiques c'est une autre
caractéristique du réchauffement
climatique par effet de serre alors
qu'avec le soleil ça devrait être
l'inversé comme le réchauffement
climatique est plus rapide au pôle
cottereau pique ça veut dire que la
différence de température entre les
pôles et les tropiques ça diminue et la
diminution de cette différence de
température diminue la force qui met en
route la circulation océanique à large
échelle et notamment qui permet à la
dérive nord atlantique d'exister ça a
une autre conséquence d'entretien de se
rendre compte en ce moment c'est que ça
affaiblit la limite du vortex polaire
c'est à dire que ça affaiblit la limite
entre le climat polaire et le climat des
moyennes latitudes puisque les
températures se rapproche et ça ça
augmente les incursions d'air polaire
donc la limite est en plus le plus beau
le plus flou ça veut dire que ça
augmente les incursions vers polaires
aux moyennes latitudes
d'où le fait que à cause du
réchauffement climatique c'est très
paradoxal on bat des records de froid
à certaines époques et inversement des
excursions vers tempéré au pôle d'où le
fait que le 1er janvier 2018 en pleine
nuit polaire en pleine nuit polaire
il y avait une température positive au
pôle nord parce que cette limite
séparative devient plus brûlante
voilà alors en ce moment elle est bien
marqué et c'est pour ça qu'on se prend
des tempêtes les unes derrière les
autres
quand vous chauffer le bouillon de
culture
les petites bêtes aime bien donc je suis
pas en train de vous dire que le
coronavirus c'est une conséquence du
réchauffement climatique par contre
statistiquement vous pouvez dire que le
réchauffement climatique favorisera ce
genre de truc c'est un des modes de
régulation du système possible si c'est
pas nous qui faisons ce qu'il faut pour
limiter nos émissions dans des boîtes il
y a des stocks de carbone qui était fixe
depuis des milliers ou des millions
d'années notamment dans le pergélisol
qui vont être remis en circulation par
un début de réchauffement ce qui va
faire une amplification du réchauffement
en cours
vous avez également le dépérissement des
écosystèmes qui va avoir exactement le
même genre d'effet c'est à dire que
quand les écosystèmes se mettent à
dépérir à large échelle
du coup ça remet du carbone en
circulation et sarre accélère encore
plus le réchauffement climatique qui du
coup exerce une pression encore plus
importante sur les écosystèmes tout ça
va évidemment avoir en bout de chaîne
des tas d'effets sur les sociétés
humaines et la seule chose que vous
pouvez pas demander à la science dans
cette affaire-là c'est de vous faire
l'inventaire précis des conséquences
possibles parce que le processus où le
système que nous avons en face de nous
et beaucoup trop compliqué et avec
beaucoup trop de processus à effets de
seuil pour qu on puisse vous dire
achtung si vous faisons ça en 2048 le 3
juillet très exactement il pourrait se
passer tel truc en algérie évidemment
que non strictement aucun sens le
raisonner comme ça pire comme nous
sommes en train de faire l'expérience
pour la première fois dans un univers
très complexe la seule garantie que nous
avons c'est que nous aurons des
surprises
c'est à dire le dictionnaire étant bien
fait des trucs qu'on n'aura pas vu venir
la vence c'est évident à nouveau un
message pour nos amis militaires c'est
évident
que nous aurons des surprises donc il va
falloir ouvrir le spectre des signaux
faibles qu'on regarde augmenter la
taille de l'écran radar
parce que c'est évident qu'il faut
surveiller de plus en plus de trucs pour
essayer d'avoir une petite idée de voir
venir les coups pas trop tard est ce que
je dis là c'est évidemment vrai aussi
pour la société civile à cause de
l'inertie du système aussi une des
certitudes que nous avons c'est qu'au
moment où l'on considère que ça devient
intolérable la seule garantie qu'on a à
ce moment là c'est que plus tard ce sera
pire
c'est malheureusement vaut mieux le
savoir il vaut mieux le savoir vous avez
évidemment tous entendu parler des
objectifs de degrés dans cette salle
vous savez maintenant on va limiter le
réchauffement climatique à 2 2 mais
alors ça veut dire quoi de jouer au
grand jeu des deux degrés vous avez ici
une courbe ou ordonnés par dont l'axé
vertical est gradué en degrés de
réchauffement depuis 1850 jusqu'en 2100
et ici c'est graduée en émissions
cumulées de co2 c'est la quantité totale
qu'on met dans la baignoire
alors on va jouer au jeu de entre 1850
et 2100 donc ici je veux regarder de
combien la température s'élève entre
1850 et 2100 en fonction de la quantité
totale de co2 que je mets dans la
poubelle atmosphérique entre 1850 et
2100 on a un premier jalon sur notre jeu
de l'oie du co2 qui est 2018 en 2018 les
hommes avaient mis au total de 1250
milliards de tonnes de co2 dans
l'atmosphère et donc les physiciens vous
dis-je va très bien des amis vous avez
signé pour 1,5 degré donc si demain
matin j'arrête les émissions planétaires
de toute façon les 1,5 degré on les tape
de toute façon on va les avoir